This is my granddad's plan alone.
You don't want her job to, this is you're
making me very, very uncomfortable.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by [inaudible] dot com and
that's o n n I t,
makers of Alpha Brain shroom tech
shroom tech sport. Had to take my alpha.
Right. I already took it once broke.
Fuck it. It was a late night podcast.
My Man Duncan Trussell
hello friends. Had to, uh,
we had to do another podcast today.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I couldn't just leave well enough alone.
He wants one of these probably.
I would love some. Here we
go. Can you snort these?
I guess you probably could. Probably
wouldn't. We were right by the door.
Huh? Um, what are, what are nootropics?
It's all,
all the information is available on
[inaudible] dot com and that's what I'm
Alpha brain is.
It's a nootropic.
So essentially it's a blend of nutrients
that's been designed to enhance the way
your brain functions. Go to [inaudible]
dot com for all the details.
It's o, n, n, I, T and nick.
And explain to you what are the
findings behind each ingredient.
That is a bin,
you know,
designed to give you like a
nice boost. It's not like, um,
anything that it's going to change
you and make you a smart person,
but it's going to make your
brain function at a good level.
But we guarantee you will
raise your Iq by 20 points.
No Dunkin and you're just making that up.
You can't do that in the middle
of a commercial on the Internet.
He just fucked everything up buddy.
Finish this fucked up the whole world.
You know, you don't have to finish
the sentence. It's written somewhere.
I tell you, he's going to need
some of these fucking Alpha brands.
Who the people living in Dallas,
Texas right now getting dusted.
I with the poison. They're spraying
over at the Kel does mosquitoes,
the West Nile up camp there publicly.
Kim Trailing Dallas with some kind
of insecticide because these uh, uh,
mosquitoes there have West Nile virus.
Nine people have died so far. Oh Shit.
That's no fun. And there's
people were just writing
about it. Somebody just wrote,
Hey, let's do it. Let's get through
with this then we'll talk about that.
Let's get through this commercial
for, sorry, Ladies and gentlemen.
The Alpha brain has
got him speaking crazy.
He wants to get to this subject before
the commercials even over. He's insane.
Gotta go Duncan Trussell so there's a
lot to cover. We have so much to cover.
I'm new to [inaudible] dot com we have
this a hemp protein powder called hemp
force, which is a amazing
naturally sweetened with Stevia,
Maca and raw cocoa or also in it.
And raw cocoa is a great antioxidant.
It's really delicious too.
It's the best tasting protein over had
an though the easiest to digest because
it's a hemp protein doesn't
make you feel bloated
at all. Your body has like a really
easy time digesting it. So I like it.
If I have to work out in like
an hour or something like that,
I can get away with it where I couldn't.
If like it's a whey protein,
I might get a little bit
more farty up in this cheese.
It's way it's way is like,
forget it.
It's like living inside a
coffin in my office. Yeah. Well,
your body's not really supposed to be
processing that kind of milk because it's
milk without all the digestive enzymes.
You,
you're supposed to drink milk only
from your mother, right? That's it.
But if you're going to drink milk from
an animal, cow's milk is the way to go.
Raw route, make sure they have an organic
diet of grass. They just eat grass.
And then that milk is actually really
nutritious for you and it has built in
like there's,
there's enzymes in it and all this stuff
that gets killed when you pasteurize it.
And that stuff is what makes
it easier for you to tolerate.
So people who are lactose intolerant,
oftentimes if you get them
to drink natural milk, they
have no problem with it.
This is like, you know how like you
think of videos that you'd like to see,
like if you got five videos that
you can see from any point in time,
you could go anywhere in time
and see like youtube clips.
I would give anything to see the
first man to drink milk from a cow.
That first person who figured
out that you can fucking do that.
Like I have so much to talk about.
Dude,
just get through this
commercial so that cause we're,
we're going to miss all the people
that listen to us on serious.
They're not going to get
that part. Oops. They get,
they come in complaining with
long ass fucking commercials.
I'm not that good at this.
This part. I'm not good at all.
i.com go get yourself some kettlebells.
Become a fucking manly man. All right.
I'm talking clean presses,
Turkish getups get with its son.
If you want to get physically fit,
Carrington flips.
You want to fucking throw some strength
into your body and put a little pep in
your step. Go get yourself some
kettlebells. Bodyweight squats,
Chin ups, kettle bells. You're
done. You don't need anything else.
Get three different ways to get a 35 of
50 when you're feeling cocky and a 70
once your cock strong from doing
it for a while and you're good.
You never have to buy any weights,
equipment ever done for life. Fuck a gym.
But then how are you gonna get laid?
Dugan didn't,
they didn't the guy tried to fuck you
regionally at the gym? No, no, no.
I tried to fuck a guy that, no, it didn't.
The guy tried to like walk
into your car. Yeah, I was. Um,
it was really uncomfortable because it's
like they, the guys like, Hey, yeah,
can I walk into your car? Right. Like
it was like the end of the workout.
Like no one's asked ever in
my life to walk me to my car.
It's so crazy the hunted, but my mind
tried to process it for us. It was like,
well, can you know my car? Is it
like, oh, you're trying to fuck.
Oh God,
you want a quick little
sweaty fuck in your car?
Oh Jesus.
That's ball
bacteria that bombing. Oh,
back here. Have you seen,
did you see that reddit and the guy had
dipped his balls in a petri dish to grow
to see what Schick rue on it.
And it just flourished with bacteria
cause there's just a sea of bacteria on
every man's right.
Oh my God.
Anyway,
go to [inaudible] Dot com
o n n I t use a code name,
Rogan and save 10% off all supplements.
That's right.
Alpha brain, shroom tech, all that shit.
Code name, Rogan, save yourself 10%. Um,
and uh, the kettlebells and the battle
ropes, the 10% does not work on those.
Those are being sold that literally
as chief as as humanly possible.
They're fucking awesome. Heavy
ropes. So like big thick, like,
like Siemens ropes. Ah, you know,
like one of those sure that you used to
fucking nautical ropes and shit. Yes.
Giant end. There's handles on
each wing and it's like, you know,
kept at the ends and you grab a hold of
them and you fucking whip him through
the air. I need to do it like in
sprints, like a 32nd sprint. Oh my God.
It's ruthless to it. It's amazing.
It's incredible workout. Okay.
You guys are like bioengineering,
some army or something
happening. You're like selling
smart pills and bound to give people
smarter, stronger, more
aware with a big quarter.
It'd be no order.
There's also a no end of this commercial
because I don't have a fucking musical
player thing. I don't have one.
So let's fake it. [inaudible]
beginning battle ropes
now starts battle ropes,
Daca Trussell the fuck is going down.
Yeah.
You know I, I just, speaking of going
down, what's going on down is going on.
What's going on? I saw a, I
really, he's being in battle ropes.
I saw this very disturbing video today.
Have you seen the thing about all dudes
with broad sorts chat chopping the heads
off pigs? Whoa. No Way. It's fucking
weird dude. Cause they're like,
oh my God.
You know like warriors,
they're just older guys that may
be a knife convention or something.
I'm not sure what it is.
They have a broad sword and they're
just lopping off the heads of pigs.
Oh my God.
Like hanging upside down.
Just lopping them off
and the fucking sword.
It really does demonstrate bloody
battles he used to be because they just,
it's like they just slide right
through the neck of that fucking pig.
Just slide through like a knife through
butter and the sound is so gross.
This flake foolish and these weird
old dudes just swinging these sores.
It's fucking strange, man. Jesus Christ.
So glad that we got past that phase of
human history that got some of the events
in a gun. Yeah. And that funny. I hate
if I got to choose, I'll take a gun,
I think. Yeah. Yeah, I'll take it.
I'm sure there's far less violence
today than there ever was when they were
swinging swords around.
I'm sure it's like no comparison.
Well, yeah, I mean you could
just think how easy it was.
If you are a bad mood to kill
somebody. Back then there was no DNA
finger up. There's no fingerprints.
If you're just wandering through a town,
you just see a,
a particularly plump young child
dragged that thing into the woods.
So why don't, why isn't it
weird? There's no amber alert.
That was not that long ago in
human history, you know? Oh no man,
we were just thinking of all humanity
is the, the humanity that preys upon.
It's young.
It's like they're young,
they're youth was ruined and so
now they want to ruin you youths.
It's almost always the same story.
So it was a scary,
frightening aspect of humanity.
You're talking about people that want to,
you know, abduct kids. Oh
yeah, yeah. But it's a,
it's almost always comes from something
being done horrible to them. Well,
yeah man, that's the opposite of this
thing called the disipling succession,
which is this idea that people get super,
super smart from time to
time by meditating or drugs
or something happens to
them. And then those people like
transmit that to the closest friends,
which gets transmitted down,
uh,
until it ends up in the present moment.
It's called the [inaudible] succession.
Um,
you know how like you get it right.
It's like one thing to hear
someone from someone happy,
but when you get around someone who's
really advanced and really happy,
you walk away with this
kind of like extra thing,
like get something into you know it
like they give you something from being
around him so that the idea is that
certain times people have like a massive
burst of that, you know, like the monkey
that came out of the tree or the monkey,
the first used a certain tool or certain
people have that exact same kind of
like blast and the people in
the close proximity to them,
they get it and it transforms them and
then they give it to the next person that
goes through time.
The simplex succession in the same way.
There's an opposite of that. There's
like a, an an anti uh, enlightenment,
anti happiness, just a foul
poison that started way, way,
way back when and gets transmitted from
one person at the next to the next and
this endless chain of shit that ends up
with like people doing monsters things.
It's quite curious.
It's almost like a race between those two.
It's weird how pliable the
human consciousnesses, you know,
it's weird how the human consciousness,
depending upon how you're raised can be
thrust in so many different directions.
You know,
it's so weird.
Like we are so not like in
an easy thing to develop now.
We're like,
we really were super duper complicated.
We have all sorts of crazy emotions,
irrational ideas of the past,
irrational views of our own memory.
You know,
and we're all going through this whole
weird thing together trying to feel our
way through it. Well he's completed.
We're so irrational. We're so,
it's such a strange animal.
Well it sucks man.
And we've got these sedimentary layers
of of of times in history where you,
you are just being ravaged by
famine and disease and yeah,
it's fuck, it was rough man.
I mean if we think about that,
like even now people aren't safe and
you can call nine one one and a half,
cops come to your house within 30 minutes,
you know, depending on where you're at.
Sometimes faster.
If something catches on fire dial nine
one one little red trucks come and put it
out. They just trucks with water inside
of them. If there's no water around,
think about that. But not very long
ago Manson that catches on fire.
It's like that's shit's going
down. You know, if somebody,
if your friend hurts himself,
you're not calling nine one one you're
going to wrap him and like 30 bandages
and just hope for the best.
It's like,
so that means that people,
there's a lot of fear embedded into us
genetically from those times. You know,
there's an angry little eight man living
inside everybody you can see anytime
you get mad you can. Yeah, that's him
howling out in the depths of your being.
You know, and yeah, there are differences.
Some people still listen to that howling
eight freak who's like terrified and
screaming out of the universe and believe
that that's them and they become that
crazy primal scared of being in.
Some people have started to realize are
completely realize that that's just one
old sort of a almost outdated appendage,
a psychic appendage stuck inside humans
and you don't have to listen to the
screaming fucking ape.
Every time something bad happens,
you can operate from another place.
Yeah. Yeah. You can. And mean
we're moving towards that.
As long as we can keep this
whole society thing together,
keep giving people food and purpose,
we can,
we can slowly but surely make these leaps
into the next stage of consciousness
yet. So we got to keep
everybody fed. You know,
he'd riots from breaking out.
It's really hard to keep
rights from breaking out when
you're blatantly lying to
people, you know? Yeah. That's a problem.
This fucking Julian Assange
thing is really good.
It gives me the spooks man,
because it's like you will explain to
the folks who don't know what the fuck's
going on, what's happening.
So Julian Assan yeah. Launches
this. A guy created a website
card, wiki leaks and uh,
he was kind of the face behind this
a website that people send secrets,
government secrets.
People sent him a shit load of files
that showed a helicopter gunning down
reporters among other
fuck that fangs. And, um,
so he, uh, he got in a lot of trouble
with the military industrial complex,
essentially just pissed off the
military industrial complex. He, um, he,
uh, and ended up, cause it's
something happened in Sweden.
No one really knows exactly what it is,
but the UK is treating it like
whatever he did in Sweden,
like he just went around fisting nuns
and setting fucking buildings on fire.
Like they are doing everything to get
them back to Sweden for what I think is a
relatively small charge. That's the
party line. I think it's called surprise,
surprise. Sachs. A very odd thing, man.
Like, yeah. And, and, and also men,
I'm not to be a complete
fucking conspiratorial Weirdo,
but a lot of people say that
there are some basic things.
If you want to get somebody,
uh, that you can do.
And one of them is you set them
up with some kind of sex crime.
You know what I mean? You can, you can
entrap somebody. I'm not saying he's,
I don't know what happened, honestly.
But you know, in society now,
if you were running an empire and you
had an enemy and a really public enemy,
it goes past the point where
you can just assassinate him.
Like in the good old days,
like in the good old days,
if someone had some information,
you just fucking Sinan is one of your
assassins to come through their window and
give them a quick snip on the throat,
leave your fucking Sigil
or whatever your sign was.
Because sometimes you want people to know
that your enemies die and that was it.
Now assassination is a little
more complex. You know,
you've got to like if someone
gets in the public eye,
they can't just suddenly hang themselves.
You know,
if suddenly a song just dangling in the,
in the embassy there, they came into the,
in the, in the bathroom and assign just
hanging by a fucking rope wearing women's
panties, right during women's
panties with maybe some caulking,
kitty porn scattered around.
We don't know.
He just freaked out in there from the
stress and he tried to do auto erotic,
a fixation cut to CNN,
CNN,
barely a peep about the libor scandal.
Boom pervert,
pedophile asage found dangling in the
embassy wearing women's underwear,
pink with Mickey mouse pictures on them.
You know what I mean? It's like that,
that's a way that they try to defame
you and make you seem like you were,
um,
not valid that you are,
no one should have been listening
to you in the first place.
That's one way to assassinate
somebody in this libor scandal.
What exactly is behind them? They were
adjusting the fucking interest rates.
They were like fucking with interest
rates, not not based on real reality,
but based on the urgings of the
government from my complete low level
understanding of this shit. But
basically it somehow is just, uh,
one of the indications of the things
that we hear all the time from some like
really hardcore can, you
know, as conspiracy theorists
who were saying that the,
the, uh, you know,
world economies are just being controlled
by bankers who are shifting numbers to
benefit themselves.
You know,
and this is like of course the military
industrial complex or war quite often as
benefiting someone in a massive way,
you know,
so it's just part of that idea that the
way things are happening on the planet
right now are based on some form form
of humanistic logic but are based on uh,
economic, um, the economic drives a very,
a very small amount of people and make
a shit load of money when bad shit goes
down. You know, like whenever
there's a fucking war,
there are people who make
so much fucking money,
man. I mean it's nice,
you know, like the way I,
if like I fucking was the bucket,
like get my own TV show. Like if I,
if I was able to sell a show, right,
that would be a big deal for me.
That'd be awesome. That'd be
an incredible moment. My life.
And that same way that I'm excited about
that. There's people who are like, oh,
come on, I ran say one more
antisemitic thing. Come on.
If we just get one more sign
that you want to attack Israel,
we can fucking get in there.
And if we get in there,
they're going to need a lot of mine
knew XP 49 double double edged fucking
missiles and I'm going to
make a ton of money. You know,
and those people have lobbyists that
talked to senators and congressmen and
their point is, the reason isn't for, um,
the reason isn't because it's like,
you know,
I imagine it's like when
you're fucking a whore,
you know the reason she's
fucking you as for money,
she's not fucking you cause she likes you.
She's fucking you.
Cause she wants money from you in the same
way. These are, these are powerful. Uh,
uh, conglomerates are making moves that
are based on their own economic gain.
I this doesn't obvious. I don't mean to be
so fucking obvious. Right. But you know,
the idea was that,
I mean,
we were supposed to be shielded
from that. That was the idea. Yeah.
It wasn't supposed to be possible.
Yeah.
When that became possible
and an obvious and policy,
that's when the real problems
began as far, I mean,
as far as like my own personal awareness,
when I started seeing it,
it became a much more blatant,
it seemed like later on in life and this
most recent supreme court ruling about
it where they said that corporations
can act as individuals. Right.
It's just insanity.
This is if she could just give as
much money as they want to give,
like you guys can work out a deal.
I'm going to be president it. Well,
how much do you want to give to my
campaign? How about 1 million bucks?
How would I love you? All right. I love
you too. And I work together. All right.
Give me some motivation.
Yeah. It's quite sad. It's a, um,
it's a sad situation. Uh, and, and um,
it's a strange situation. It's a
strange situation and uh, it's a,
it's a situation that up until this point,
I mean,
it was pretty easy to hide
this shit. Yeah. You could
really control information.
Yeah. You can. People can just look in
their phone and fucking Google anything.
Yeah. It's almost like everybody's waking
up going, wait, what, what, what, what,
you know with what the effect reminds
me of Joe. I just fucking bought a TV.
I'm an American. I haven't had a TV
in so long. I went to fucking, um,
best buy and bought it. God Damn
One of those nights, logins.
You try to be like Mr Bohemia
and I don't need a TV. It was,
um, I don't know. Since I've been in
that fucking house, I am nine months.
The TV is awesome. Anybody who tells
you the TV's not awesome is an asshole.
No TVS. Awesome. No, I wasn't, I didn't
have a TV out of some hate for TV.
I didn't have a TV because I understand
my composure and a plug that Xbox and
pop in Skyrim and just vanish
from society for four years. Yeah,
that's my problem. But the
thing about new fucking TV
is, um, the pictures too good.
It's too clear.
It's like you watched the x men and it's
like seeing like people just walked out
of like a, uh, I don't know, a
fucking West Hollywood aerobics class.
They just look too real. It
looks silly. It's too real.
It something about the
pictures too. Good. Yeah.
There's a different quality to it where
it makes old movies look like shit.
Yes. It's too good. It looks silly.
No one looked really bad, man.
I saw aliens to the other day.
The, the movies still holds up.
It's still a great movie,
but there's some background scenes where
they had a painted spaceship. Yeah,
and it was so bad because it's so obvious
and not with the incubator with Hd.
So in the same way,
it's weird because it's like that
technology is imitating I think what's
happening to people's
perception of things.
Somehow when a president starts doing
the presidential talk or when you see a
like what's happening in fucking the
UK where they're saying where the
[inaudible] no, no, no, no. Listen,
we have a right to what
we have to enforce this.
This is the deportation
of a sauna to Sweden.
It is has nothing to do with a thing
where he leaked terabytes of information
about the military industrial complex.
Nothing to do without that.
That's just a coincidence.
We've got to get him out to Sweden
because he did a surprise rate.
Now surprise sucks and pride.
It's a pride sex.
I guess it's kind of the same thing,
but what happened was they had had sex
and then he was in bed with her and then
he had no condom. Can I stop
you for a second? Supposedly,
I want to apologize to everyone
that I just used the word Rape Dan,
so sorry. I said that word.
I will never use it again.
The words done.
I will never use that word.
I've taken that word and I
have tied it to a fucking bad.
It's the new faggot rapist. The new
failure. I don't even mind neuro.
My neurological system
cannot process that word.
I don't even hear that word. I don't
hear any bad words. I've got a new,
I've got an, I've been taking
a, an a new fucking arm,
no tropic and makes it so that I can't
hear offensive words really can enjoy a
comedy show cause nothing ruins a comedy
show more than when it comedians that
something unethical or
immoral. Ooh, I hate it.
I'm just trying to have
a good fucking time. You,
I don't want to be lectured on what
you throwing your lefty beliefs my way.
Oh my lefty beliefs. No, no,
no. I'm saying to the comedian,
what's our hypothetical
comedian that we're just making
out? Yeah, I don't I, yeah,
you comedian person blogger,
swamp toad helping.
We got our sold the mouth shut.
We got so the sinner's mouth shuts.
We can't let them speak.
We can't let them talk about the things
that happen in the world. We don't like.
What is so weird about people
that they're so easy to program?
Like they're going to be programmed so
many ways and you gotta look at like
people in North Korea like all
crying for real in the street.
When they did their dictated died.
I mean they were like for real legit crime
on the street and then look at people
in America and seeing how much
different we aren't. Then you know,
the people in China, people
in India, it's so we're,
we're so adaptable and we're so
fucking variable. We're so different.
It's such as we have the strangest
fucking animal ever. We are a strange,
we are strange fucking creature man.
We went from background to foreground.
It's like all the,
it's like animals are so absorbed in
the nature when you watch a fucking
squirrel running around and you see how
like in nature that thing is just part
of the earth, almost just the earth.
Humans are like a few steps past that.
So it's like we came out of a picture,
we like came from the background
into the foreground. This is the,
this is the idea that uh,
they tried to metaphorically talk about
in the story of the garden of Eden,
which is,
you know,
eat before they ate of the tree
of the knowledge of good and evil.
They were unaware that they were naked.
It was like there more, more animals.
And then this represents a, I
think Mckenna has said, you know,
this is the representation of the,
uh, expansion to the neo cortex.
This is the beginning of human brain
development is suddenly becoming aware of
ourselves, of our bodies, of the
fact that we have a fucking body.
Cause you know, animals they don't
think about they're buttholes,
you know,
like dogs aren't thinking about like
what their balls look like when they're
running. They're not thinking about their,
their fucking hair. If it's messed up,
that doesn't cross their mind at dogs.
Never worried about its
hair being messed up.
But humans like we fixate on that shit.
Like we spend so much time thinking about
how ashamed or ridiculously we proud
we are of our bodies.
It's fucking hilarious how much time
you really consider how much time you
fixate on your body one way or the other.
We're,
we're just into our bodies,
so yeah, man, that's this. Um,
that's one of the weird,
bizarre aspects of human being human.
As you're aware, you're aware of
all the stuff you like. You know,
you're aware of why you love, you
like you. It's a puzzle to you.
You see a woman with a thin waist and
then a big ass and big breasts and you're
like, you don't even know why there's
like, triggers are going off evolutions.
Like that's the shape you're looking for.
That's the shape you're looking for.
Calves,
calves from being accentuated by the
high heels and little fucking weird.
How weird is it that every woman
shaves her legs? Like you have to like,
that's not really what their legs look
like. Especially girls with dark hair,
you know, any, anything like really,
uh, w will it be the word spicy?
You know, and he like Greeks
or something along those lines.
Italians love those girls.
If they didn't shave their legs,
oh my God.
Do you know what kind of you'd be
looking at was the longest. See?
Have you ever let your, your whole pubic
area grow before he trimmed it? Yeah.
Do you have a trim it? Yeah, I
trim it. But there have been long,
long periods where I'm sure the
thing is just, if you look at it,
but it's just ridiculous. It's like all
over the place. It's just a cabinet chaos.
Chaos. Chaos. Yeah. But,
and then you imagine that
covering your entire body.
And that's what we used to be.
Just like a lot of people still are Bush.
Never see,
was it George George the Animal Steele?
Is that what's his name was so wrestler,
I think it was George,
the animal steel something,
the animal Steele. And he was,
he looked like a fucking gorilla.
He's the Harris human being ever.
And he was huge. He just as
big giant fucking, you know,
superhuman muscles and hair covering
his whole body. Robin Williams.
Uh, this guy was more freaky. Robin
ones is pretty fucking Harry's. Yeah.
But this guy is built like a gorilla
to though, I mean it's like, it's like,
it's real close. I mean, he was,
he was in, um, one of those movies.
Um, one movie was, I feel
like he was in a movie.
I'm not remembering it right. Well
man, the thing, I think he did,
I think he had a career in like
horror movies or something.
We're very close to something that just,
it's no longer here anymore,
but people's minds are still, some people
are still functioning at that level.
Uh,
and,
and in some people know that some people
are still functioning at that level and
understand how the nervous system works
and are really good at tricking people.
You know,
cause once you're like,
just like if you still identify with the
howling screaming animal inside of you,
yeah. You're really easy
to manipulate. You know,
it's not that hard to fucking trick
a monkey and going for a banana.
It's like legendarily easy to
get a monkey to go for a banana.
I want you to come over here and just
look at what George Steel looks like.
So you see what, what, what kind of
ridiculousness I'm talking about. Ha.
Can you imagine?
It doesn't look real huge
dude covered in hair and he's,
he's bent over looking at you like
he's about to charge like a solar back.
Looks like a stop motion character from
clash of the titans or sounds hilarious.
That's weird. And he did some
acting think it was in like,
yeah, he was in ed wood I
believe with Johnny Depp. Yeah.
And he it on a fucking
crazy looking and do,
but he used to like eat the corner like
you live, whatever. I'll turn buckle.
He would grab it and bite it and
start eating it and ripping it apart.
He was fucking crazy. What a weird
life that must have been. Huh?
We had a professional wrestler.
Yeah. That's a really weird life.
That's one of the weirdest aspects of
our culture ever. Professional wrestling.
You mean like worldwide wrestling,
world wrestling, entertainment.
I haven't watched while wrestling
since the great Kabuki man.
People still love it, dude. I was the
only, well it does really well. It's,
it's fucking crazy. What is it man? It's
like a form of fucking dance basically.
Isn't it? Like it's like choreographed
fights. Yeah, they, you know,
are fake but it's fucking hard to pull
off to it. And those guys getting beat up,
those guys are always throwing each other
down. Right. The Shit. But it's not,
it's not real fighting. It's like a form
of gymnastics. Tumbling. What's a work?
You know? It is what it is. It's a hard,
they do what you call it would
call hard work or they really,
they slap each other occasionally
they'll fucking, they'll close online,
each other.
They really slam each other to the
ground and you could really get fucked up
doing it. They all have like, you know,
back problems and shoulder problems.
And the cool thing about it is not just
the fact that they're fake fighting,
it's that there is a narrative.
Yeah.
Weird ruin a rudimentary narrative that
runs through the fucking thing where
they, everyone's has rivalries.
Yeah. And, and there's, uh,
there's always a villainous guy has
g like generally like supernatural
undertones. Like maybe he's come
from hell or something. Right.
There's like always that the taker,
yeah.
These mysterious men who've emerged from
like the darkest parts of the world,
the slap each other's backs really hard.
When I was in high school,
it was Bob Backlund,
he was the champion and the big one was
that everybody wants to see fight for
the title was Jimmy The superfly
snuck a Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
And it was a big deal.
Matt and he would put up his three
fingers like this and he would go,
I love you.
Those what he was telling everybody
when he had his fingers up,
I love you. And they fly
through the air. He would fall,
lie through the air dude inland on guys.
And what a beating his body must've
taken doing that, man. I do.
Do you ever did some ridiculous shit? I
remember when I was a kid. Yeah. Okay.
Getting into some fairly serious
arguments with people over whether or not
wrestling was real. Oh, hook is
you, it'd be like, no, no, no.
This is fucking real dude.
Do you think this is fake?
You fucking think the great Kabuki,
like a guy could just blow steam out of
his mouth and poison a man. He's real.
You are getting these like deep,
oh yeah.
Before they had to admit it
was fake for like, right.
But you see that tax purposes,
you see it's still happening. See,
this is the funny thing. It's
still fucking happening. Yeah.
Only now when you tell
somebody, you know, um,
our Congress is bought by corporations
and it's not really representing the
people anymore and you can, you cannot,
you, uh, you know, that's, um, that's,
that's real.
It's pretty obvious by now.
You tell that to people and they'll
be like, no, it's real. It's real.
It's real. It's the realest thing there
is. How could you say that's not real?
These men, these fine men,
not the high seats of power.
They're not getting bribed
by corporations. No, never.
They have integrity yet again.
And again, time and time again,
we see that people have been supported
by lobbyists to the point where I saw
someone, um, uh, put like on one of the,
I think one of the presidents or I
don't remember which it was. Maybe he's,
I don't remember who it was.
Maybe Baner the guy looks like howdy duty.
I can't remember who it was,
but put all their main corporate
sponsors like a NASCAR outfit. You know,
like they said like senators and
congressmen should start having to wear,
I think Robin Williams had that in a
special, oh it dead. Is that what he said?
I saw a picture of it on the
Internet, but, but the, the, the, the,
the, it's the truth. But
there's still people who want,
who don't want to believe
to believe that's the truth.
And this is the fucking problem man. Cause
it's not just politics, it's religion.
You, you, there's people. I just
have you seen this fucking I,
it keeps popping up on the Internet,
but it's like this idea that evolution
has had that the way some an or the
creation creationist believed that the
way some animals got from one continent,
the next is from graphs of the
forest sup rooted by the great flood.
So like bears and rabbits and squirrels
were just like floating across the ocean
on logs.
Like they,
people believe that stuck creation is at.
Dude,
imagine that just labs covered in
rabbits and puppies and eagles.
It's this craziest thing
fucking ever. But, but,
but people believe that right now.
Well,
there have been guys who have invested
money to try to design and recreate the
arc. How did thank you. If
could have worked. It's just
been dudes have done that.
Like there's some rich dude, I think he's
in Holland and these uh, recreating uh,
an art right based on cubits and what
are the flood could ever fucking crazy
measurement they use back
in when the Lord's work.
How many fucking lunatics right now?
How many crazy people right now in
neighborhoods and trailer parks across
America are in their backyard constructing
an art cause they think God told him
to build an Ark.
I bet there's at least 400 people right
now hammering in their backyard on a
fucking arc because they had a weird
dream. Our God told them to build an Ark.
There's definitely more than one. I've
definitely heard of more than one person.
Talk about grandiose. Imagine you thinking
you're really Noah, but that's like,
you know if your cuckoo for
cocoa puffs, that's a, that's a,
that's an entertaining one. You think
you think you're Noah? Oh my God. I mean,
but dude, imagine if like your fucking
brain speaking to me. Wait, what?
Hope what Joe?
It is high the Lord. I'm going to
flood the planet because I'm pissed.
That's why I always thought it's hilarious
when you see like a fake seance or a
seance. It looks like obviously full
of Shit. Hold on, I'm getting a signal.
He saying he's saying there's
a hole or his heart used to be.
What does that mean? Does anyone know
what that means is speaking to me.
I just fucking saw on Trinity Broadcasting
Network. If you ever watched TBN. Yes.
So I just saw some remedy broadcasting
network. This fucking televangelists say,
do you want that new house?
Do you want that new condo?
That $2,000 isn't going to get
you a condo or a new house.
Plant that seed money in my ministry
and it will come back to you 10 fold.
A hundred fold.
So this guy is on Tbn,
compelling people who've been saving
up their money to buy a house,
to send that money to
his fucking ministry.
He's tricking dumb asses and just
funneling money to him in the idea that
they're going to send $2,000
and because he says it,
it's so terrible what he does. He's
like Trump. He's aiming it though.
If people like, uh, illegal
immigrants, one of the things
he said is, ah, you know,
won whoever since $2,000 to me,
his green card had already been denied,
but he went to the mailbox and you got
a letter underneath his bills and he
opened that letter and it
said he had been accepted,
his green card had been accepted.
So you're like trying to hit these like
the most desperate humans who are like
as a combination,
desperate and dumb,
watching TV late at night and they
just have a little bit of money left,
but maybe they're a little drunk.
Oh, you're like, yeah, this is it.
This is what I need to do.
This is what I fucking need
to do on giving money to
the Ministry of father fuck
face and it's going to come back.
It's crazy
doing that. That's seeding.
That's pretty recent.
That used to be just a donation thing,
but then someone came up
with the brilliant idea of
saying that you're planting
seeds and that you get it back.
Well let's see the pause and just
a donation anymore. It became like,
you know what I mean? Like it wasn't
like that for a while, for a while,
donations, but the problem
is, man, with all this stuff,
this is where religion gets confusing.
It's a lot of the metaphysical principles
these people were throwing out there.
They're real. If you put good energy out
into the world, it does come back to you.
It is true. If you put, if you
put good things out in the world,
it's like throwing a fishing line out
and it was a really good chance you're
going to reel back something awesome
that you didn't expect to get,
but it's like these sons of bitches,
they're like making it as though there's
an actual spiritual economy in the
universe where if you did,
there's some kind of new quantifiable
bank account balance where if you send
2000 you'll get 20,000 based
on some specific crazy laws.
That's, that's where it gets
odd and that's where it's
kind of fucked up because
it isn't. It isn't because the wounded
antelopes have always been jacked by the
waterholes. That's just the
way it always been. Have.
You're so fucking dumb that you think
that that guy's really going to be able to
do that with your mind.
It's almost like you're,
you have to exist as an example of folly.
You have to exist as a,
as an example of like when anybody gets
scammed by one of those Nigerians. Yes.
One of them, I watched this
one thing were talking about,
it was a dude who was really sad, man. The
guy just didn't have any companionship.
He didn't, didn't,
didn't have a girlfriend,
really wanted a girlfriend and it just
spent all his retirement money sending it
to this Nigerian scammer,
went to Europe to meet this chick twice,
twice, twice. You kind of broke down
during the shower. Brutal because
he, his Pr, his daughter or someone had
to tell him that the woman wasn't real.
Someone close to him who was trying to
explain to him at the moment wasn't real,
but he just wanted to believe he
went to Europe twice to meet her,
do it twice and like she said,
she couldn't find him. Oh my God.
I'm getting called back by my family.
Right. And this poor fucking guy bid it,
but it hook,
line and sinker.
And everybody spoke to her
and just kept sending money.
See,
it's really cool mag because we keep
going back to talking about believing in
bullshit and the effect
that it has on your life.
The immediate detrimental effect it
has on your life to believe bullshit.
No matter what the fucking thing is,
it always fucks up your life.
Whatever the fuck it is.
If you believe in something that's crap,
you end up making decisions based on crap.
And so you've just summon more and more
negativity into your life from believing
in bullshit now where it
gets fucking weird man.
And where like there's a part of me that
is always combating what the apparent
violent and brutal merciless aspect
of nature with my own instinct to want
everybody to be okay. And, and like,
those two things are really fucking
confusing for me because you look out into
the world, you know, and you, you see
any on the nature channel just, you know,
watch a fucking hyena taking a bath and
the carcass of a fucking elephant or
watch fucking, uh, those, those tigers
in the Russian circus. You just attack.
Those dudes are look at the
fucking, um, uh, in China though,
the monstrous way that they're, you
know, slice the skin off of living dogs.
Or you can go on and on with
examples of this kind of brutal,
the slaughter houses everywhere, you know?
Right. The brutality of nature, you know,
and, and, and, and,
and you can go into this Nietzschean
mind state where you're like, you know,
yes, that is, that is as much a part
of the universe as anything else.
And then there's another part of you
that if you start thinking that way can
become a bit, uh, a bit nihilistic
where you start thinking like, oh,
well, if there's a wounded antelopes,
then why help them, you know what I mean?
But let let them suffer
for their own good.
Let them come to understand life through
their own transgressions that they can
grow on their own and become
powerful by their own volition.
And that's fucking cool, man. There's
part of me that really loves that idea.
And then there's another part that's
like, yeah, but what if, you know,
there's an actual concerted
effort at work right now,
a concerted effort by a
kind of a combination of
many different conglomerates
who have recognized the psychological
makeup of most human beings in and figured
out very intelligent ways to intentionally
manipulate those human beings to
become consumeristic so that
they can gain at, uh, from,
from these people's lack of
education and understanding.
I think you're very educated.
People are often consumeristic as well.
I think consumerism is a byproduct of
work and doing a lot of work that you
don't really want to do.
It makes,
it makes you want to buy things when you
go enjoy buying things when they work.
That's part of it.
But this is like from this,
I think we've talked about this before,
the century of the south, about the, uh,
what's called black psychology
or the, uh, the, um, uh,
using psychology been to manipulate
people into buying shit or giving them
ration that they need
something, right? So it's like,
but it's an art form that
they've almost got down to us
and it's a necessity.
If you're going to have a successful
economy in a capitalist country,
you got to keep selling shit,
right?
You don't want to make something
that's going to last forever,
but how do we regulate
it? Do we do, we do,
we just let it happen so that you can
have preachers that you can have like
those crazy guys on TV saying that if you
send any money, I'll give you 10 times.
Do we just let that happen? I mean,
what, what if you were a, a few,
we're inclined to decide,
you know,
if you had to cast your vote one way
or another, what, how much do we limit?
Well, no. Yeah. All right. I'm
sorry. I just want to say like,
because if that guy's not legitimate,
okay,
what if something comes
along that is legitimate?
What if there's some
sort of sustainable new,
a environment that's being built and they
want everybody to throw some money in
and become a part of it
and uh, you know, and,
and the offer you like a tangible deal
and it's based on the same sort of
spiritual concepts,
you're going to automatically connect
it with those other assholes. Well, no,
I know. This is the prop man. I
mean, this is, I can't stop it.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like you couldn't stop it because it,
you would limit stopping it
for a real pool. Going to
stop it too. Yeah. He was
going to make the decisions.
Who is going to say, no, no,
no.
This is the right thing and that's the
wrong thing and this is good and that's
bad. It's like, it's almost,
uh, uh, I only an EGOMANIAC,
whatever even consider the notion
of trying to take charge, you know?
And so it is this, you know, we,
we ended up in this curious predicament
of trying to determine, okay,
well then how much do we let happen?
For example,
what's happening in Syria right now?
How much do we let happen?
How many more people get fucking bombed
in this weird war between an oppressive
regime and the people who are rising up?
And it is an oppressive regime.
The guy's been at, like, the guy's been
around too long. The elections are fucked.
It's, Siri has always been notoriously,
it kind of fucked up place.
It's like now there's a civil
war happening. So how much do we,
who's it, who takes the side of, you
know, right? Who takes the side of Assad?
That's his name, right? Assad.
What? Who takes his side?
Who's really going to stand up for that
fucking guy? You know what I mean? And,
and, and I'll tell you one person
who is Russia, you know what I mean?
So Russia is standing up for this guy.
Now we're in a weird situation.
I don't know how much they're supporting,
but the,
that's where things get fucked
up because it's like, okay,
I guess we just back off and let a
bunch of people get slaughtered because
that's the way of the world.
This is like, you know,
the hardcore libertarians believe this.
I think Ron Paul's like,
this isn't our business.
Well, his, his also,
his contention is that we've created a
lot of business that we shouldn't have
created.
We've made things our business and things
we've had blow back because of things
that we've done that we shouldn't
have been doing in the first place.
The idea of a policing the world.
Yes, that's a problem.
And we definitely split,
put our fucking dicks and
a great many Hornet's nest,
but it's like the, the, the,
uh, but if you look at it from like
a perspective of just you, you're,
you're getting your apartment,
right?
You're in your apartment
and two doors away,
someone starts screaming bloody murder,
right?
He's fucking,
oh, Jesus. What do you do? What do you do?
Are you going to fucking
call nine one one?
Of course you're going to try to help.
To,
maybe you're maybe going to go over there
and see if you can fucking help this
person. Right? So now all of
a sudden there, let's spread
the radius out, you know,
two buildings down that's happening to
someone. Now, let's spread it out more,
you know, two miles away at a certain
time, someone's going to get fucking hurt.
How, when do you stop helping? Yeah.
And right now it appears that when you
stop helping [inaudible] is when it's
outside the fucking, uh,
boundaries of your country.
At that point you're like, no,
no, no, no, no, no.
It is the way of the world that people
are slaughtered by mortars in guns and
executions and dragged into secret
prisons. It's the way of the world.
And then it's a really weird fucking
situation because it's like, well,
it's also the way of the world to get
people out of fucking secret prisons and
to help people who are in trouble. You
know, it's the story of our fucking,
you know, our history, the damn
the French helped us, you know,
it's like sometimes people need help.
When do you help?
It's a real fucking question.
It's a real,
it's one of the big questions
facing us right now.
It's like when do you do something,
you know, like if a in the UK,
if they fucking storm into the equity,
the embassy that Eh, the
Ecuadorian embassy. Do you
say? What does the Ecuadorian,
yeah,
they storm into that fucking thing.
Breaking the sovereignty of Ecuador,
which is essentially invading Ecuador
if you go into a fucking awesome. Yeah.
So in that case,
obviously when they,
if they just fucking start
throwing out the whole game, yeah.
Or that it's gotten where they're like,
you know,
we're just going to do what we want and
what will for as long as it suits this
will make it seem like there's laws
in place here, right? Well, no,
it comes down to it.
We're going to fucking do what we want.
Isn't that kind of crazy that you got it
like a whole building that's different
country and that building has sovereignty
in this cat can go there and say,
can I get asylum? And they're
like, yes. Good, cool.
I'm staying here and now you're
still like, wait, hold up and wait.
He came mentioned with the
stress of being in asylum.
Can you imagine the stress
of being Julian? Uh,
it's a must be unbearable.
I mean the guy, he's crazy,
but he has a giant Paul's
giant, giant, giant
dude. That guy's going to be remembered
as one of the great heroes, man.
That son of a bitch, that
poor fucking bastard. Nobody.
That guy made a real goddamn
sacrifice cause like,
I don't care how much money
he was making from wikileaks.
I don't care if he was making a fuck
load of money for Wiki leaks, man.
He knew when he wait,
leak those documents.
Do you realize like when you get that
much fucking information that shows that
some fucked up shit is going on.
The moral responsibility to ethical
you are responsibility you have at that
moment. Because you know that the moment
you wet this shit out, you're fucked.
Right? Forget it. Forget it. Game over.
You've made the decision like, all right,
I'm going to fucking throw myself on the
fire in this incarnation just because
it feels better than sitting back and
festering with the knowledge that there's
fucking innocent people getting
gunned down for no goddamn reason.
And that's being kept away from the
people who are funding the fucking bullets
blowing up their heads. You're like,
God damn it, I've got to fucking do it.
And you do it and you're a bad ass.
And then you end up fucking
hold up and the guy,
a God damn embassy and you know that
even if you do get out of that embassy,
even if 50,000 Guy Fawkes mask
wearing anonymous vigilantes,
the send on that embassy
all wearing the same outfit,
swarm the fucking embassy and give you
the outfit to wear so that you just mix
in with all of them and
vanish into the fucking,
into the darkness and then end
up in fucking Ecuador. You know,
at one point there's going to be a moment
when you wake up and there's the guy
sitting next to your bad and he's like,
hey man,
I'm sorry but I got to
fucking kill your ass.
Or maybe it doesn't say anything or
maybe they poison you or maybe there's a
fucking moment when you walked down the
street and you feel a strange prick in
the bottom of your leg. And the next
thing you know, you get a weird sickness,
a form of fucking swine flu or
some odd bacterial infection.
You just fucking die.
So tell me more about what's
going on in in Dallas. I,
it's a West Nile outbreak,
apparently nine people dive now there.
When did this happen?
I don't know when the outbreak happened
and I kind of like keep my eyes peeled
for any kind of like end of the
world style plague reports. But yeah,
it seemed to pop out of nowhere.
Just eight people in Dallas
came down with West Nile
really recently. Yeah. Really
recently. I dusted there.
I think they're dusting today.
Jesus Christ just spraying out
that fucking poison, you know,
because they don't want the
West Nile virus to spread. Yeah.
The Texas gets fucking funky hot man.
And apparently I'm Aubrey said that
they've had a record amount of days.
They're, they're cruising on
the, the, the current record,
which is like some crazy number,
like 50 something days
of over 100 degrees,
hottest fucking summer in history,
man. It's weird, man. It's weird.
You know, we were talking about, um,
like lakes drying up and rivers are drying
up and shit like that. Yeah. That's a,
that's a disturbing thought, man.
That, that the climate can shift
like really radically. Yeah. And it
always has, always had, always had us,
our ideas that we're going to be able to
stay in this one spot that we so choose
to set up shop in. That might be silly.
There might be a silly thing to do. Yeah.
It's like, as a species, we do this thing,
same thing people do as an individual,
like as a species, we make the silly, uh,
like we have this crazy idea that
everything's gonna stay the same. Yeah.
The planet's gonna always be
hospitable to our former life. And uh,
we've just live with that. And
the same way that from, you know,
individuals go around like they're
going to lift fucking forever.
They go around treating people like shit,
not returning phone calls, you know,
they'd go around like being
like complete conscious. Those,
there's going to be something fun
to treat people shit. Fucking,
I don't return phone calls.
No funny that is pissing my brother.
Uh, all, all the horrible shit you
could have said someone does like, yeah,
people are fucking dog shit.
I love returned.
My brother is like,
I love him very much.
He's like one of my best
friends on a fucking planet,
but he's found somebody that
he really loves and it's great.
It's really
so he's like,
he's like absorbed into this,
this
beautiful thing that I'm
very happy for him for it.
But it's like that classic thing on one
of your best friends gets a girlfriend.
You're like, fuck, I understand.
I've done it. God knows I've done it.
I've been the king of that Shit,
man. It's horrible. But the point is,
people treat their lives, and
I've tried, tried to do this last.
Now sometimes people get
caught up in like the, this,
the minutia and they ended
up, they end up, uh, uh,
discounting their existence is though
there's going to be some point 10 years
from now, a lot of people
think, okay, you know,
I'm just going to fucking party through
my twenties and then your 20s paths and
then 30 seconds I got stills,
got some juice in mistake,
I'm going to just fucking do it through
my thirties and then your thirties pass
and now you're feeling a little tired and
fucked up a little bit in your forties
comment and you're like,
under the forties,
I'm going to settle down and I'm
going to really become a man.
And then you just Keel over and die and
that's it. You never fucking did you not,
you never actualize yourself.
You never jumped into the,
you never jumped into the fucking fray.
You know what I mean?
So in the same way as a species,
it's like we're,
we're in that situation where we've, we
think, yeah, well it'll be fine, man.
There's infinite fucking resources. Woo.
Come out. And it's, you know, and now,
now we're kind of like in that
part where you look in there,
you flip the fucking hotel mirror a little
bit and take a look at that pink moon
sprout. And in you're in the back
of your fucking head. What the fuck?
There's a patch of pink. They're in the
same way. There's like nice big thick,
black,
oily patches,
a death sprouting up all over the
planet from people logging and Dumping
Chemicals in there. And like, no,
it'll come around that little fucking
radioactive patch called Chernobyl.
We'll come around.
It'll be fine in a couple thousand years.
You know what I mean? It's like I'm
not even no Fukashima. We'll be fine.
It'll be fine. That's not getting, that
won't affect the rest of the planet.
Why was it so crazy? Yeah,
it's fucking crazy. So,
so this is where we have
this fucking problem, man,
because we've got a group of people who
believe that rabbits floated on rafts
from one continent to the next.
We've got a group of people who really
fucking believe in some very archaic,
primitive bullshit and we're really
letting them run with it. Man.
We're really letting them run with
that. You're, you're supposed to,
if you're polite,
to allow them whenever craziness
they believe without ever arguing it,
ever discussing it or ever disagreeing
with it. Yeah. And it's fun. It's like,
it's fine. Okay man. Fucking believe that
shit. I don't care. I really don't care.
And if it makes you happy,
I really do mean God bless you
and I'm happy. You're happy,
that's fucking awesome.
But if you're making political
decisions based on these belief systems,
well we got a fucking problem,
man. We got a big fucking problem.
Cause you're making political decisions
based on an imaginary voice in your
fucking head that thinks that a floating
man's going to come down from space and
this is a problem.
This is a problem because the decisions
need to be made on a more realistic
human level, which is like, hey, there's a
lot of people on this fucking planet. We,
um, we, uh, we, we need to
start working together and uh,
and stop blowing each other up
as crazy an idea is that may be,
it's pretty much time to put down the
Bible. Let's put down the fucking Koran.
Let's put down the,
let's put down the old crusty old fucking
scrolls and just treat it like we're
living in a neighborhood. And
let's see if we can fucking, um,
let's see if we can just stop blowing
each other up for a second. Iran,
you don't need nuclear
missiles. Iran, let's not make
nuclear missiles and Israel,
let's not fucking attack Iran right now.
No, none of the people want to fight.
None of the people want war. We don't
want to die. I don't want to die.
I don't want anybody to get fucking
blown up. None of us want that man. Well,
maybe like,
maybe there's 3000 of us who want that.
Maybe there's 3000 people who
really are into it. And that's it.
And there's a lot more of us than there
are of them, you know. So at some point,
something has to happen where a shift
takes place, where people start, uh,
prioritizing what's actually happening
over what people dressed in funny outfits
are telling us. An invisible man
is saying, we should do, you know,
it's like so obvious.
For example,
if like you're in the woods and you
get to choose between two guides,
there's a guy wearing
camouflage, he's like, got to
fucking go Rambo knife and uh,
uh,
some fucking awesome tattoos.
And then there's the guy who comes out
dressed in a black fucking cloak holding
a book and he's like, this is a magic
book. This is my magic force book.
And this book will give you all the
answers you need in this giant, massive,
deadly dangerous snake filled
bear, written, forced. Do.
Are you going to pick the guy with a magic
book or the fucking the, um, the, yeah,
we go with, okay, you go
with the Kmo fucking guy.
You go with the fucking Cammo guy.
Maybe you take down the guy and the
funny robe and steal his rubbed,
make a Hammock, but you don't
fucking, you don't fuck it up.
You don't follow the
guy with a funny book.
Well unless your brain doesn't work
that good man, that's a problem.
I think that one of the
things that religion can do
for people that really helps
is it gives you an operating system and
I think intelligent people use it that
way and I think some really dumb people
use it that way and if they didn't have
it, they wouldn't know what to do
and they might actually be a problem.
I think it gives people an
operating system and all
though I don't agree with it.
I think it's like I've described it as
like religion being like scaffolding that
it's like scaffolding for
expanding consciousness.
It allows you to have like some real
solid shit that you don't have to think or
worry about. Yes. And then
concentrate on being positive,
helping your brother being, you know,
being a generous person. It's a vehicle,
a vehicle for. And if you know
you need stories or you know,
scripture or whatever it is that you
need to get you into that frame of mind
that puts you on that good scaffolding,
this shit's encode it,
man. It's, it's a fractal.
There's deep information and all the
scriptures. I certainly, um, I, when I,
they are all so different and the rules
are so different, you know? That's true,
man. I know some of them are
just not into being happy, right?
Well, no, no. Well, yeah, we'll see
what it is, is, it seems to be a,
a problem of literalism,
you know,
it's like people are reading things
and taking them literally and so,
and not looking into the deeper levels
of things. This is happening, um, uh,
in every single aspect of our society,
it seems that people are becoming more and
more literal. They, they, they, the, the,
their understanding of symbolism parody,
that kind of stuff becomes a,
it seems to be a little muddied right now.
For example,
the most recent thing that happened
is, uh, as you know, I know,
you know Daniel Tosh and the fucking
rape fiasco for example, right? Yeah.
Now Daniel Tosh,
and I know this has been chewed gum on
this show, but just the third podcast,
oh, comedienne Chabay talking
about it. These bastards.
What a steal. I wired's the,
the, um, the, uh, the, the, so
the, so someone, when you make,
when you deal with things on the
surface level and you don't look deeper,
well then you get into stupid wrestling,
semantic wrestling matches with comedians
over the most ridiculous ideas ever.
Instead of just like, yeah, he was
like throwing something out there.
He's not a rapist. He
doesn't want to rape. Uh, he,
he's just threw something out there.
It's no problem. You know, the Depo,
just a little, just three inches under
the surface of that fucking thing.
And it's a yawn. It's a yawn, mostly
just like whatever. But like, um,
on the surface it's fucking so important,
so very fucking serious.
So in the same way people take
these very powerful scriptures,
they interpret them on the on the level
and they start arguing about the fucking
surface level. So now when people are
talking about the fucking garden of Eden,
they're arguing over like who?
Who was the bad guy?
Was it eve or was it ad and well it was
Eve's fuck cause she listed that darn
old snake first.
People really think that.
They're like yeah it's the woman's fault.
That's what she got cursed
with a painful child birth.
And there's some of that in there, but
it's like come on fuck heads, come on.
Like if you say so then when you look
at like when you get into the fucking
Kabbalah and you look at the cobblistic
tree of life and you see something
that's taking the fucking idea of the
tree of life in the garden of Eden and
deepening it to like that,
it really much deeper part of the fucking
fractal where it's an expression of
the expansion of nothingness
into something that's in
the universe and it's a
cool metaphysical grid that shows
the thing becoming aware of itself.
Or a thing waking up and then
becoming aware of itself,
creating a triangle which flips over
because it reflects itself into the
universe and these are our, it's
deep. It's heavy shit and you can,
it's fucking awesome because this
Kabbalah, that's the good, the cobblistic
tree of life and then assist the stuff
that you're not supposed to even read
until you hit like 36 or some shit like,
yeah, that's what they say. I mean,
I don't know. I don't go to the
Kabbalah Center or anything.
I just remember reading Alice to Crawley
and he's got like some fucking snake
sound to confirm your allegiance
with Satan. You're a grown man.
Oh, let me tell you I,
I've used it as son.
I found myself his name from time to time,
just for the fuck of it and hang out and
feel good. Hang over. You go hang over.
You feel like a vampire vampire
is look like right? They look at,
they're hung over. Like when
the sun comes up, they do.
They look fucking what a weird idea is
that sometimes you can have vampires that
fall all the vampire rules. Until real
recently people got so fucking arrogant.
They were like, well, no, no, no.
Now Vampires are actually your friend
and they only eat deer and they don't
burn. When it's sunny out.
They just glisten and they
don't want to be glistening.
They sparkle Joe. They
don't glisten. They sparkle.
Just vampires all of a sudden became
cool and you could fuck them. Oh yeah.
Well that's Andrew Rice's fault.
Right? And rise or fall. Oh my God.
The fucking interview with a vampire.
I don't think so man.
Because even before interview with
the Vampire, Dracula was very sexual.
The Dracula was a hypnotic.
Yeah,
he was a very sexual and like a
lot of the older movies, you know,
there was a few of the Gary Oldman. What
came first? Gary Oldman or Anne Rice?
Probably in rise, right? I don't want
Gary Oldman Dracula. I think Anne Rice,
I'm always positive actually.
Well,
no, the fucking old Dracula, I think
the, the Brahms Stoker Dracula.
Oh that was so long that some traps and
the castle didn't he have like there was
a room you went into and there are all
these female vampire is running hot.
Is there a car? Yeah and like they were
seductive and would like, you know,
they would know how riffle Dracula,
that's the good part of that where
everyone is hating on Dracula.
It's got these hard pitches
that want to suck blood.
They're ready to throw it out.
It just gets the bone him.
He never bound them in front of
you buddy though. It was just,
I guess once you start drinking people's
blood that's like way cool with him.
The one in checks just
completely give up on bowling.
I mean in the world of vampires it's that
is boning the best track though of all
time. Unquestionably. It was Gary
Oldman. Did you see that one? I don't.
Bram stoker I got so it's so good
that Keanu Reeves can't fuck it up.
I got it like I don't know
cause I haven't seen it,
but I'll tell you my favorite
fucking vampire by the way.
I do like Keanu Reeves.
It's just as cheap joke. I like
canneries. It's cheating. It's the Joe.
I love you can, I love God. I love
you. Didn't pay attention to my joke.
He just went in and say,
what are you going to say?
Here's where my mind started wandering
is you said the greatest vampire and then
I thought, no, no, no. The
greatest vampire of all time,
the spookiest vampire of all time is
fucking Nosferatu. Oh, the original. Yeah,
you're right. Fuck that thing. We'll also,
that was like really original. I mean,
and think about that guy did that. It
was like, wow, this is a silent movie.
No Man, that thing was a
scary son of a bitch was like,
that's what a vampires like the
long fingers kind of gobbling,
just as creepy thing pops out
of the shadows that talks.
I do keep talking. I love it. Sorry
my, my yapping too much. Oh, I love it.
Oh you do? Really? Yeah, man. Yeah, man.
That guy's fucking scary. But you know,
the Salem's lot vampires
are pretty fucking spooky
to 1922 brother 1922 and I'm
looking at the images of it right now.
Oh my God. It's, it's fucking incredible.
It is legitimately frightening.
Legitimately frightening.
And it was in the fucking early
19 hundreds, dude rentable.
And they find fucking coffin stilted.
You know,
they found coffins out there where people
have hammered stakes into the Oh yeah.
Well there's probably,
I'm sure people that were fucking
assholes and they just wanted to make sure
that really never came back.
But this motherfucker was
creepy. You're right, man.
You know, he might be the
scariest one ever. Yes.
Especially when you consider it was
90 fucking years ago. Yeah. Man,
that was fucking spit. Well, I mean,
that was based on the real thing.
Whatever was wandering around out
in the fucking woods of Germany.
That's what was out there. What
a crazy people. Do you remember?
Uh, it was, uh, it was based
on a real man. The, Oh my God,
look this fucking photo of it,
dude.
It's a really good God damn image that
they're really fucking scary looking.
Yeah,
that's a scary vampire.
1922 because if you go wash like King
Kong, King Kong is not really scary.
And that's a little from like the 30s.
Nope, not scary at all. And that's scary.
It can con can,
cannot fuck with Nosferatu.
No, not, I mean, I guess if I had
to pick who I wanted to run from,
it's going to be a fucking
Nosferatu though. But I weird.
Is it that they just hijacked
the whole vampire thing?
Vancouver is used to be the worst shit
that could ever happen to you and now
he's a hunky guy. Well, I'll tell
you why they fucking did that ship.
Rather we in it. Yeah. You got to
sell it to teenagers. It's women, men,
lot of women Wa people that
want that want romance. The A,
the thing about the twilight books,
so I've been told by Mrs Rogan, uh,
is that the very romantic,
unrealistically romantic because he's a
vampire and it's like he's got all the
super power and everything like that.
It's like he, like he's giving it all up,
but just to be with her, you know what I
mean? And it's this weird sort of like,
he, he needs her so much
and women love that shit.
It's just a natural sort
of a thing for though.
So like when you see like women that
would be waiting in line to go to those
movies, that just, it just hits a
chord that we don't, we don't have,
we don't know that court,
but the who wrote that shit and I
was their cord so she nailed it.
Love.
I'm talking about the court
of affection and admiration.
Like I think all women want to be,
you know, they want to be worshiped,
you know,
they think that that's like the most
romantic thing for a guy who would do
anything for you. So he would do
anything for that girl in, in,
in those books he would do
anything for, I mean, he,
he didn't even want to bite
her. He wanted, uh, you know,
he wanted to protect her from everybody
who was in love with her. Meanwhile,
he was like a thousand years old
and she's in high school. Like,
it's really fucking creepy if
you stop and think about it.
He's a thousand years old
or whatever the fuck it is.
I tell area she's in high school,
man.
You're fucking crazy kind of
conversations you're having with her.
Jesus Christ. I mean, it'd be
hard enough if you were 30,
you were 30 and you're dating a
girl in high school, you'd be like,
I got to kill myself. I can't
take it. I can't talk to her.
She's fucking just shows.
All she wants to talk about
is Instagram thousand old.
You fucking creeper. He's a total
creeper. She could be as Greg Greg.
It's not like he just was frozen for all
those years. Like captain America. No,
this asshole's been alive the whole time
and uh, pretended he's in high school.
It might be one of the dumbest ideas ever.
It's not fair. He's got magical powers.
He can fly. He's flying a
fucking high school kid through
the trees. Jesus Christ.
Did they fuck yes. Eventually. Yeah.
Later in the boiler spoiler.
Yes. Allegedly. How about that?
I don't know. It was, it already
happened. It might have already happened.
I only saw like two of them.
I think there's been three of them.
Put it in her asshole.
I don't think vampires a lot to do that.
It's a sin. Even for Vampires.
I think we've vampires. No,
no, no female that go cut the shirt.
Just stop it. They don't even shit
anymore, so probably drives up nice,
don't shit. When you're eating blood,
they probably barely a urinal dude.
You probably get the exact amount
you need. You don't know that.
I would imagine you would get to the exact
amount you need now, man of vampires.
Asshole is swollen.
Broken a scene where you walk down into
a New York City subway and you saw some
crazy looking vampire dude,
you're shitting blood.
Just blood squirting out of his ass.
Chunky cottage cheese blood.
That's what a vampire he looks
like a tunnel, a subway title,
just shitting blood,
looking at you and thinking
about sucking your blood next.
It's weird that they're like, that's that.
That's as far as they go. Like vampires,
suck your blood.
That's the worst thing I do.
But there's never been like a supernatural
creature that walked that like mouth
fucks you. You know what I mean? Some
we talked about that before. You know,
he really, as ridiculous as it is, I think
we actually did talk about this before.
It must be on my fucking mind,
man.
There's no fucking bat or
some creepy for rapes people.
That was mouth rape and dudes.
I don't use that word.
A fucking horrifying, horrifying
being. It doesn't have to be a vampire.
It could just be some bug,
some insect or something that came out
of the earth and that's how it does it.
It just fucking,
it leaves off of the,
it lives off of like people gagging.
That's it absorbs the energy of gagging.
It gets power for the trip.
The twitching of your body when
you're trying to throw up, it's a gag.
Pyre pipe is clogged by a fat
cock and you can't even throw up.
You're trying to throw up and he's just
holding the back of your head was Scaly
Paul. That's what they came to
do. They just came to get head.
They have like really tough dicks, like
you really cannot even pierce the skin.
You can bite it as hard as you want.
It doesn't matter when alien's face fuck
you. They just did. It just goes in.
You accept it and it, it just fucks
your throat when you try and throw up.
But he can't get past the fat alien
cock that's stretching your insides out,
pumping oxygen. And by the way,
it's keeping you alive in your life.
It changes your whole,
it blows your lungs out and
actually eats them and uh,
converts it to a type of glue that keeps
the cock attached to your body to keep
you alive.
Cause now you no longer have lungs.
You get all your oxygen through his cock.
Oh my God. Could you imagine? That would
be the word. And some people would say,
you know what? I don't
care. I love aliens anyway.
There's still all Sarah teaching us.
Listen,
if for him might be really awesome.
Maybe he loves the fact that he's
getting the oxygen to that cock.
You stay alive, your body where
there's a way I can't really move.
Your arms are flailing and like in paled,
you just look like a skeleton with a
fucking Gildo in its mouth and every year
it just goes deeper in your body,
keeps debt growing.
Eventually it turns into the
age is turning it like a Cactus,
like cactus Dick thing. Yeah. If
you look at sugar, Barb shish Kebab,
Dick Kebab, every year the, the,
the s the dick slowly grows inside your
body and starts cracking open Oregon's
and pushing ribs to the side,
popping them and snapping them as it
eventually goes through your body.
But it does it so slowly that you never
actually die, especially since the, uh,
the deck is providing with oxygen, but
then when it gets to the head, to the end,
the deck pops out of your asshole and
you deflate like a balloon. And that,
and that sound is that
sound is known as fumbling.
Like it's like the sound of a man's final.
Fom there's no words sound. It's like a
cute, I mean, that's not any weirder
than a lot of shit that's real.
It's not any weirder than those aquatic
worms that just stayed inside of
grasshoppers and committing, get them
to commit suicide so they can be born.
That's an and that's enough.
No, man, this is this. I know.
It's not that fucking weird and not weird
at all. Right? But it's like we don't,
the closest to harder movement course.
It's weird, but it's the weirdest thing.
But it's not any more weird than like
cordyceps mushrooms that grow inside ants
heads and then explode and spray the
air and affect all these other ants to
become zombies.
Fucking Nah, I god Damn my bane. Ling's
God bless you. Starcraft two our is,
I love you. Um, it turns, it
turns him into bombs, right?
It turns into fucking, uh, bombs.
That's a fungal bomb. Yeah,
it's crazy. Um, uh, yeah dude,
fucking the, the nature is insane man.
And like I sometimes I think about that
notion of the fungal consciousness and
factor, the thing that like, uh, you know,
the, I know, we know this is chewed gum,
cause I know we've talked about
toxoplasmosis for example.
I had to describe that today to Everlast.
I'd explained to him about cats.
But Dude, if you take this
the next level, you know,
this is where we get into the realm,
the metaphysical realm that, um,
a lot of people believe that, you know,
you can get fucking possessed by a spirit,
right? And this is not just fucking
Christians. This is like an,
almost every religion
has this notion that uh,
I think you can get into you and start
fucking controlling you. And it's like,
man, if it's, if there's fuck, you know,
maybe there's this embodied beings
that really can like get inside you,
you know, maybe, maybe just certain ideas.
Is it maybe like certain ideas? I think,
um,
what's his name?
Stein or someone was just telling me he
believed the ideas were alive. Right?
And so,
ah,
what if there are certain ideas that
someone can implant into your head?
That's the exact same thing as being
possessed. You know what I mean?
So you get this fucking idea
and it just grows inside of you.
Much like our legendary Dick Alien.
It grows inside of you and turns you
into a fucking different person. Yeah.
Is it hard?
There are certain people that are so
susceptible to ideas and words that they
can get them in their head and
obsess on them. The point of almost
like madness. Yes. I
had a friend who had a,
a nervous breakdown while he was
hosting a show where there was a,
a a black gentleman who was the
actor in the show, very famous guy.
And as he's, um, he's warming up
the crown Brody Stevens style,
he gets this thought in his head that he
can't get out and the thought is don't
say nigger, don't say, Nigga, whatever
you do, don't say that he could,
he would never say it. He's not a racist
by any stretch of the imagination.
It was just madness.
Yeah.
So we had a complete nervous
breakdown while he was doing stand up,
while he was warming up on some Hollywood
sound stage and he just had a nervous
breakdown. He just, he couldn't
not think of not saying that word,
so it would just completely
fucking freaked them out
to the point where he froze
and he couldn't get any words on.
People were concerned about him.
They were looking at him like,
is he okay?
Like he just stopped in mid sentence
and everyone's listening to him.
He's got a microphone. He just locked
the fuck up with. And I was like, wow.
Oh. It was like, what is that like
possessed by an idea.
The idea possessed them and took over
his body and there's other versions of
this idea,
you know,
whatever the fucking idea is that gets
in someone's head and makes them think
that a solution to a problem is the
wrap explosives around their body and go
wandering into a fucking cafe.
That person's got a bad idea.
That's a bad idea inside their
head. That's a bad thing.
Living inside their head.
Yeah, it's a bad idea. And it's like,
there's a lot of fucking
people on the planet.
You've got some bad ideas and their
fucking heads, man. Yeah. You know,
but you know, they're just, I suppose
whether they're living or not,
it's just a device to like help
understand the spread of the thing.
And this spreads more like a virus.
Ideas spread more like a virus
than they do anything else. Right.
They fucking take over a person.
They get into its subjective DNA.
They transform its thought patterns and
then not being begins to infect those
around it with the similar ideas.
And then that spreads the fucking thought
disease out through it through the
world. Do you know? Right. And that
that's like going on right fucking now.
Right.
God Damn Chick-Filet I'm going to go
around at chick filet and eat some fucking
chicken sandwiches to show my love for
Jesus. Yeah. Right. You know, and, and,
and like that's a Vr,
you know, that's the,
a flower growing from the tree of an
idea that's been planted in the minds of
many people. Um, you know, the
fundamentalists and it's like, fuck man,
what if it is a living thing?
What if they're actually possessed by
a living force that is not that great?
It's just like that fungal things in,
in the answer the tree.
That's interesting.
That's an interesting way of looking at
it that these ideas are actually living
things. Yeah. I mean it, it
might be, who knows? I mean it's,
it is very strange when you think about
the direction that our society goes and,
and then it does seem to be led to and
fro by like really saying shit upon
occasion and Saint Saint Saint Shit.
And you're like, wait a minute,
what are you doing? Because she did what
she danced. What, what? This is your,
this is your belief. You
know, you get a line,
a woman up in the middle of the street
and throw rocks at her because someone
caught her dating a member of the wrong
Muslim tribe. Yes. Oh my goodness.
It gets, it gets weird man.
Really scary. Weird. Well,
it gets fucking weird because I mean
goddamn the first fucking when, when,
when the first monkey decided to come
down out of the tree and wander out and
start fucking hunting, you know,
I don't know. I don't know. But I,
I'm pretty sure that the other fucking
monkeys that decided to stay in the
fucking tree and in this situation,
I'm not saying one group is a monkey
and one group's not. I'm saying we're,
I'll fucking monkeys.
But the ones that decided to stay up
in the Goddamn tree didn't have nuclear
weapons.
You know
that's about the nuclear sub that was
sneaking around off the coast of Mexico.
Shared Ed right down near San
Diego. Russian, right? Yeah.
Having a little fun Russian nuclear sub
gut right up next to us. Just a slight,
you know, bitch, Holla and sneak
up on you. Armed with warheads.
Sure. Easy. It was a real
legitimate nuclear submarine.
Check it out. What the fuck?
That wasn't a message. Oh my dear.
I guess they're there for awhile.
We didn't know they were there.
I guess my gps was off.
I ended up off the coast of San Diego.
Most of the symmetrical,
most of the bullies
are onstar malfunction.
Malfunction gps. Yeah. How crazy is that?
There was a war ship. The other superpower
that wants to get bigger and better.
What's he? He's run by criminals.
Here's where we come to the fucking,
you know the, the, the, the thing
that mechanic kept talking about,
he's like, look, we don't have time
to teach people and meditate anymore.
People are possessed by this fucking idea.
We can teach people to meditate,
but first they need to get
super high on a psychedelic.
You know what I mean?
Like there needs to be this,
there's like this imperative to
transform those fucking crazy thoughts,
structures that are floating
around in people's heads, um,
because they've got fucking
nuclear weapons. Thanks Fran.
You can't just climb out of the
Goddamn tree. Now, you know,
if you climb out of the fucking treat,
people are going to say you're a
goddamn heretic. You know, they're your,
you're a Goddamn anti American heritage.
Listen to me say there's no fucking
Jesus Christ and the God damn rabbits got
across the fucking ocean in some way
that didn't involve floating on logs.
You're obsessed with this rabbit
and the ocean thing. Well,
they didn't say rabbits, but I just
picture that I just said animals.
I don't know. I don't know that spread
of rabbit throughout the planet.
I'm not floating around on logs.
Oh yeah. But some of those four,
you know what else is apparently
everywhere on the planet? Sasquatch.
Yeah. Well, yeah, you fucking laugh,
dude. But I'm going to squash.
You're getting known as a a Sasquatch
believer that's happening to you.
I'm down,
I'm steady squatch and look man,
if you ever watched the show finding
bigfoot? No, I just got a TV.
I had bobo from finding big foot on the
podcast was awesome. He gave me a, uh,
a cast is a cast over there. I'll
show it to ya. Foot giant foot hat.
Does he believe it? Oh fuck yeah. He
believes it. He said he's seen it.
He said he's seen it, man. You know,
it's really creepy though. Really?
Northern California, that whole
area, it's called like Ape Canyon,
Ape River Monkey Canyon.
It's like all these like weird
fucking names and involve primates,
but it's not a place where there's
any apes. It's really strange.
There's a lot of sightings in one area,
a lot of sightings for the last couple
of hundred years and it's a really
densely wooded area.
It doesn't mean that they're not
bears and people aren't on mushrooms.
It's totally possible that it also could
have been just an idea that one person
had and they ran with it and it fucking
carried on as almost a tradition.
Okay.
Not to take this idea too far,
but fucking mechanic talked about
the idea that the Ufo is some kind of
projection of the Mystere
of the mystery of novelty,
of the something within humans or
something in fucking hyperspace.
I think that was young.
Yeah. Carl Young. Carl Young,
maybe Makino has quoting young. Yeah.
It's um, aliens and Ufos and archetypes.
I forgot I forgot the book, but he wrote
a whole book on that concept that the,
uh,
the Ufo was almost like a,
a ghost of our imagination.
So maybe this is probably a
terrible way of describing it.
Maybe this is a ghost of our imagination.
It's a kind of specter that rises up
out of the deepest parts of ourselves or
our potential and manifest is like,
this is what we could be, or this is me.
Have you ever seen a real UFO footage or
real photo that you were like, yes, I'm,
I'm, I, I have seen pictures,
but every single picture
is always fucked up.
They had a new Saas coach picture
and all they got is his back.
Crystal clear and focus is bad.
Yeah.
One shot man, you sons
of bitches. All right.
But it's not saying that there's not a
real animal and the reason why I say that
as Jane Goodall, Jane Goodall,
so she was 100% convinced.
All the people should talk to that at
the same story and all the same side of
things. If there was an undiscovered
primate in the Pacific northwest,
I have no problem. I mean, it's never,
it's not anything that fucking wood.
I think it'd be really awesome if
somebody finally like caught one of those
things, but it wouldn't, like,
it's not going to make me fucking any
happier when I wake up in the balloon
would make me happier. I love it. I'm
like a little kid. I'd be so happy,
but I think what the fuck
do I know about primates?
A lot of what I know about primates came,
they learned from Jane Goodall.
So for me to like pretend that I know
more about primaries and Jane Goodall just
seems ridiculous.
So Jane Goodall says there's a climbed
without doing too much research,
I'm inclined to believe it. You
know, I mean Jane Goodall is,
she's a bad ass bad ass lady.
The lady scholarly lady.
Thank you. But she's um,
may I ask you a question
for show me good off. Sean.
You think she ever humped
one of those for sure. Yeah.
Fuck the shit out of at least one.
Just to see what was up.
Maybe that's what kept
her all those years.
I think a lot of those ladies
that they want it, fucking chimps.
Chimps have big dicks. You know,
it has that big Dicks, gorillas,
gorilla girls,
a little tiny decks.
You know why no one is trying to fuck
their girls. Look at the size of them.
Jesus Christ, the gorillas,
the back's the smart ones.
You think about what they are.
They're these giant,
enormous but peaceful vegetarian gorillas.
It's like nature just made them so big.
So you leave them the fuck alone and
it works so good that they can have a
Harem. So they have a heroin.
There's no need to grow a big deck.
He's not about the size of your Dick.
You don't have to impress these chicks.
They're yours.
Go ahead and get that one.
So they have like these little tiny dicks.
I'm like an inch long.
They're always fallen out. The grill
is a terrible fucking Christopher Ryan,
the author of sex at dawn talks about
this. He was telling me about this.
I really,
how gorillas have a fucking tiny
little dicks because they have a hair.
Yeah, it's exact. There's no like
competition to grow like big cocks.
It's one thing else. All chimps have
huge balls too. It's all chimps.
Chimps have sluts, female chimps
just taking dick all over the place.
So the mail chimps, their ball
swell disproportionately with sperm,
depending upon how much, uh,
promiscuity is in their clan.
So if everybody's fucking,
everybody that balls are giant and they're
just ready to shoot loads on a drop
of a hat.
You got to be ready to fuck one of these
crazy bitches whenever we can hold them
down, that is banging each other left
and right. Especially like Benobos.
They're the craziest animal ever. They
have sex to, to uh, get over arguments.
They like men and men that
this is the women and women.
One of the premises in this book,
which is the Banabos are
closer to us than champs,
are equally distant and you can ask
them genetically. So it's like, and,
and they fuck missionary position.
They look in each other's eyes
when they're humping. Yeah.
I think there's some odd lesbians shit
that happens out there and there and just
sexually promiscuous.
They, yeah, it's a social,
it's a way to solidify
social bonds through humping.
They do everything except the mother
does it. Fuck the sun. That's it.
That's where they draw the line.
But other than that,
that's how they resolve issues. Father
Fox, daughter, father fucks daughter,
uh, brothers fuck sisters. Oh,
but the mom does not fuck the
sons. Nope. Yeah, it's strange.
Or they got something right.
That's step one, bitches.
Next try shoes
that never going to evolve because they
have the fucking thumbs on their feet
and they want to fly around the trees.
They're not going to lose that.
Why would you lose that?
That's the most awesome thing ever.
Flying around in the trees is way better
than any cool shit that we can do on
the ground, you know? So for them to like
develop cars and all that other shit,
you gonna have to spend a lot of time
just walking around with shoes on.
Well no man, this is where we get
into the IBM. First of all, man,
I love the fucking idea. A monkey
starting to wear shoes that would,
that would make me wake up happy
to start off with catcher's Mitts.
How cute would that be?
Like you see film of like monkeys,
like in the cute little sandals that
they've made at a Bush baby who can't.
Do you think it would work? I
wonder if it would work. Sure.
I wonder if I could wear a men walk
around all catcher's Mitts on. Sure.
They could wear anything he could
wear. Fucking does tee shirts, helmets.
And God damn boxing gloves,
it'd be the best. What would,
what do you think we would do if we walked
in and chimps in the jungle and they
were making shoes and we're
tying their shoes on? No, no,
not even weapons to shoes.
We'd we shoot them. No,
we'd weep with joy because it would
be the cutest thing anyone ever saw.
And also you'd be on the front
page of Reddit. Like yes,
it would be totally on the front
page or when it would explode.
And also it'd be like, you
know, it'd be kind of like, um,
uh, really spooky thing. Like,
which is this idea that maybe evolution
itself is accelerating and all beings,
not just in fucking technol technology,
but like,
it's like hitting everything.
It's starting to speed up everywhere
where those gorillas popping those fucking
poacher traps.
You know what I mean?
Like maybe shit's happening everywhere
is speeding up and speeding up and all
think where things are suddenly
going to just start like talking,
wearing fucking shoes,
talking and cute English accents.
For people who don't know, the girls
are figured out a way to disarm traps.
They know, they figured out
the mechanism behind the trap.
So that triggered the trout to working
together. It's really fascinating.
Really fascinating. They figured out a
way to communicate their idea and they uh,
they took out some traps.
Yeah. I mean, what would we do?
What would we do if they started evolving?
What would they do with,
they started developing weapons, you
know, if you came into the jungle,
then you found chimps and they were
holding on to spears with Flint tips.
What the fuck do you do? You know,
what do you do that gets crazy?
And what if they're just using it to hunt?
They just use it at the hunt within
one day. One tells a dog, you know,
steals a dog in Africa or somewhere
and the next thing you know,
it's on the war. Could you imagine
if they actually did evolve?
What if chimpanzees, this is a
fucking stupid idea, strap in,
but if you listen to Mckenna's idea,
Mckenna's idea of the stoned ape theory
was that there was a period of human
history that scientists are a
little bit confused about it.
And that period is over 2 million years.
The human brain doubled and they don't
know why. They really don't know.
There's all sorts of thoughts, you
know, like the throwing arm like that.
We figured out how throw shit and kill
things that accelerated our use of tools
and the rain just kept up with what, you
know, what we needed. And then the other,
the craziest one is Mckenna's idea.
Mckinnis idea was that it was because
of mushrooms, is that we had, uh,
started coming down off the trees because
the climate was changing and that the
rain forests were receding in the
Glock grasslands and that these animals
flipped over these cow
patties looking worms and shit
that they would eat.
And then they found the mushrooms on
the top and they started eating the
mushrooms and then they started
experiencing enlightenment.
They started having creative ideas. They
started developing language. I want,
why hasn't someone just taking some
champs and giving them some mushrooms?
Why? Why don't they try
that? Why don't they, I mean,
if you're willing to try lipstick on
them and let's see if this perfume is
fucking toxic. When we Turkey shoot
it up your ass. Yeah. You know,
they'll do all that to champs.
They do testing on chimps from
medicine and they die. They, it's,
they do hard shit to them.
They cut their heads off and see if
they can keep on fat allegedly. Um,
but why I get the mushrooms.
Could you imagine what if they could
show we've been doing this for 45 years.
We'd go to some fucking bunker in Nevada
right out and groom lake like these,
these are the chimps that we have
developed through our mushroom program and
they look like cave men. Yeah. Could
you imagine we've had him for 36 years.
This is where the,
and they look like,
man, that's, if that's the, I mean if,
if only we could have whatever that
fucking beam that they had and I star Trek
that genesis ray or whatever,
that makes shit of all faster because to
me makin his idea of the Proto Hominids
chomping on those mushrooms was that,
um,
it happened of course over a long, long
time, 2 million years, 2 million years.
Cause it create and, and, and like,
it's like mushrooms at low doses.
This is the other thing he mentioned in
his theory, his mushrooms at low doses,
man, they're great for
fucking dude. They're great
for having sex. They're like,
they really like, it's if you take the
right dose it's real. It's an aphrodisiac.
Yes. So like his idea was um,
yeah, so there's, it's like,
it also improves visual
acuity and the peripheral,
which so you can see a goddamn
wine sneaking up on your ass
peripheral.
But they said that they've done tests on
where they have two parallel lines and
a one parallel line will
move very slightly offline.
And when we you, you can recognize it
quicker on psilocybin than when you're,
when you're straight. Weird. Yeah. Um,
I forget who, what the scientist was.
Who did that? I should know. I should
remember that. What it was, uh,
one of the, uh, the things that
Terence had as a part of his theory,
but nobody ever took his theory seriously
after everybody got completely mocked
and made fun of it. Because mushrooms
are like an inherently silly thing.
Have you say you've done them,
where you think they're important
year immediately. An idiot. Silly
sub. And what'd you, what'd you go to?
A grateful dead concert and dance
on a tapestry. God Damn Hippie.
But what's amazing,
it's like,
it can be responsible for one of the most
powerful reconsiderations of your life
ever. Like a real true
religious experience. Yeah.
And we're all holding
back on all this shit.
None of those were trapped
in this wonky culture.
We're all sort of at least partially
got the brakes on when it comes to that
stuff. No, they got the brakes
on us. We don't have the brakes.
The brakes aren't on that.
We got conditioned.
The Reagans put a lot of
fucking money into that Shit,
man. Like this wasn't like,
uh, the administration, of course, not the
family, but this was like the, you know,
this is the pharmacological
inquisition as they say. Yeah. And uh,
it all stems back to the,
uh,
distribution of LSD
through the United States.
Starting with the CIA's experiments
does eve, they had a truth serum serum.
And um, the, you know, the ways I get it,
what psychedelic is due to society is
that they fucking meltdown the boundaries.
And when boundaries meltdown,
it causes a shift.
And that shift is not work very well
for the way we've run our society for a
very long time.
And so they recognize that and
they stop that shift because it,
um,
it's not,
but it's important to realize that
these brakes are being put on by people
outside of us. I mean, if you look
at shamonic cultures and the Amazon,
you know,
these are,
this is a indogenous
part of their daily life.
It's embedded into their culture. It's
as normal as having fucking telephones.
You know, it's a way to communicate
with nature. So this is like, you know,
a very essential aspect of being a
human being is taking a psychedelic,
um, um, has been for a very long time. Uh,
and you know,
whether or not Mckenna's right about
the neo cortex expanding and when Proto
Hominids chomp mushrooms,
one thing is for certain,
once we found out about it,
we indulged. What do you mean?
I mean that's for certain, yeah.
Once we found out about it,
people have been using them forever.
Bingo. Yes, yes, yes, exactly.
Glee.
And we know from our own personal
experience with him that the effect is not
some kind of like, um, ridiculous, uh,
a frat party giggle fast.
It's like if you take the right dose and
you do it with the right people and you
do it with the right intention,
then there will be a massive
shift in your consciousness.
It can do a form of ego death,
which allows you to heal and allows you
to reacquaint yourself with kind of a
living, connective energy that isn't
all things. And um, that's an eight.
That's a very important
experience to have.
But it's amazing how all the propaganda
worth considering how substantial the
effect of the product is, that it's
suppressed. This incredible, you know it,
I mean you would say
that in an open market,
eventually the cream rise to the top,
but it doesn't get a chance because it's
cut off and because it's illegal and
demonized this incredible,
I dunno whatever you would call it,
experience that's called, that
it's incredible experience
is kept away from you.
It's kept away from what is essentially
a natural experience by eating some
things that people have eaten since the
beginning of time and it's kept from you
and it's,
it's a shame.
It's a shame that you can live your whole
life without understanding that there
might be some other aspects to this life
that we also need to take into our body
in order for us to get a
better grasp on things.
And they might have aided getting us
to here and we might be in a sick, sick
time where we're not using these things.
And that's what's responsible
for this whole chaotic community.
That we have this whole chaotic thing or
we're polluting the skies and polluting
the ocean and you know, we, we
will do anything for profit,
including invade other countries were
doing all sorts of really insane twisted
things that are the types of things
that would be happening if we were sick.
If there was something wrong with us,
if we weren't getting our medicine,
if we weren't getting, we were weren't
getting what got us to the dance.
Right? Yeah man. If that's
true, if that's true,
if the human consciousness really
did develop through psychedelics,
it only makes sense that we fucking need
that shit. Just like we need meat. Yeah.
It's a vibe. It's almost like a vitamin
or it's like it's not a psychic vitamin.
And in the same way that way back when,
during right after the
agrarian revolution,
when people are getting less nutritional
value because of droughts and they
became amazing,
aided and small,
and you can look at skeletons of people
back then, they're much smaller, right?
Cause they weren't getting the nutrition
in the same way. We are amazing.
[inaudible] but in a, in a psychic way.
So you end up with these people or these,
it was just broken fucking psychic egos.
Pro Wrestling fans. Hey, he
fucking pro wrestling. No Bro.
I fucking love pro wrestling and I
love your show too. I love you too.
I'm just kidding. Is this a joke? Yeah,
I got nothing. It's progressing, man.
Take it.
I'll take 700 fucking stadiums of pro
wrestling fans over one Phelps family.
You know what I mean?
Let's talk about that.
That was Fox man. You know crazy.
God hates fags guy. They're insane.
When you say fell up,
so you have to be careful cause it's
right after the Olympics. You know,
people would say, what the fuck did
Michael Phelps to? Oh, you know,
you might have fucking pig
felt. Jesus Christ, that guy.
How does your race swim so fast? He's not
even like a human man breaks the laws.
Did you see the onion headline that
Michael Phelps returned to as aquarium in
New York? Like he lives in
acquirement and sea world. I mean,
or when he goes to the beach,
he was like, no fucking way.
I'm getting in that water and he's like,
I've been in water so much,
I am not fucking swimming. Like he
doesn't ever swim in the ocean. He's like,
I'm just sitting in the sand. Chelan
I don't blame. I mean fuck dude.
That guy's like, how many gold medals
did that guy won more than anybody ever.
It's like in 20 or some shit. Something
nuts. He moves so well. It's incredible.
I mean it's just like from an aesthetic
point of view or a, you know, from an,
even in an artistic part
of you, you, you're,
you're looking at it and it looks
like art. It looks like he's like,
it looks like a dance in,
there's so much flow to it. Yeah.
As he's like fucking hurling through
the water. Yeah. It's so the,
they move so fast that it's
hard to believe, but it is
almost, I mean if dance,
I mean if it really, if dance
is impressive, isn't that
impressive? Just as well.
I think it's an impressive
physical feat in to a rhythm.
The way they can swim to a rhythm and
then they'd go under and then they show
underwater flight this long period before
they bust open and start whipping it
again.
What a crazy fucking sport man.
Wild to watch. Wild to watch people do
some shit that you just cannot fucking do.
To know that. That's like the
capabilities of the human frame. Yeah.
If it's that long and that strong and
that young and that dedicated and it puts
in this many hours every week,
look what the fuck this thing.
Yeah. It's pretty amazing. Ooh,
it's pretty amazing. All this stuff,
they can happen and, and, and
physically, mentally what you can learn,
the things that you can figure
out. It's amazing the, uh,
the amount that you can send your
consciousness out into the universe and
understand things. It's
a fucking incredible, you
know, th th this, yeah. This,
this space suit that we're in.
It's like,
it's got all these like a parts to it
that we forgotten how to use. You know,
almost like some survivor of a spaceship
crash has amnesia and isn't this super
advanced spacesuit and only
uses like parts of it, you know,
little parts of it to like amble around.
Right, right. And it's like, no man,
there's like crazy fucking circuit boards
that you can access in this fucking
thing. But you know, you need help.
There's certain fuels that you need to
like make that connection and those fuels
are fucking, if you're an athlete, you
got to eat the right food. You know,
you can't just chomp on guide.
Damn Froot loops and Cheetos and
ended up like being a professional,
a Olympic swimmer. They've got their
feeding. Those people like crazy.
We don't even know.
Probably glows smells like calm cause
is special nutritional like blast that
they just spray into their mouths like
fog roghey's there's fucking like,
you know, God only knows what
these fuckers have in their bodies.
And in the same way for your
intelligence, you know, for your,
for your spiritual growth,
you need to take into your fucking
being certain at certain things.
Great scriptures, incredible
writing. And on occasion,
a nice fucking mushroom trip,
you know,
but you gotta be careful, you know,
you gotta be careful not to like,
I feel guilty saying this stuff
because some people are, aren't,
you're not supposed to take it.
You shouldn't take it.
You're in a bad part
in your life right now.
You're fucking balls smell like at the
bottom of a God damn fucking the bottom
of a, a donkey's ass. You know,
you got to clean your balls and clean
yourself and your life up before you take
the experience. You know,
some people shouldn't do it,
but some people definitely should. You
definitely should. It's very important.
God Damn.
Just one on a hippie rent and my
friend Steve Jobs though, I mean,
come on, like you said, that fucking
LSD was like one of the biggest, uh,
one big part of his
understanding of the universe.
Yeah.
I think we had a world filled with people
of all had breakthrough psychedelic
experiences and they were running this,
this country.
It'll be a lot easier as long as they
got enough pussy to keep them satisfied.
Yes,
we just had robot concubines or whatever.
People would think it would
be morally acceptable,
keep them sexually satisfied so they
don't go tweak in and they don't do stupid
shit and undermine our world just
based on their need for pussy.
Dude, by the way, you don't need robot
concubines you send out into the world.
Hey Joe,
it could be a form of the military like
a suck his cock and especially with the
troops satisfy the geniuses
sexually like some branch.
What if that was our fucking
military like troops train,
just a suck off geniuses
and make them fucking happy.
What if that was like how we
like that's how we went to wars.
We just sent troops of fucking blow job
masters into the homes of geniuses and a
complex just sucking
them off of their habit.
Yeah. That's where they would take, they
should take like all like super geniuses.
Just bringing some sub place. Fuck getting
pussy. Fuck having this ruin your life.
We're just going to bring you constant
Betches we're gonna pay you well,
we just want you to be really
creative time machines. It's crazy.
And you want a family and you want to
start to have children. We can see.
We can arrange that as well. Yeah.
The mastery simulators they do,
but then they want all the money.
They want to take it.
They want to take all the money, like a
bad record deal. Yeah. And anybody who's,
you know,
when you're creating things for companies,
well the here's,
but here's the thing man.
One thing you never
hear when a kid's like,
I want to be an inventor
is another giving.
Like you're going to get a lot of pussy.
You know what I mean? If that,
if that happened, we would be,
we'd probably be floating right now.
We'd be floating on a magnetic field,
sending like our fucking thought patterns
out into the world instead of talking
into microphones.
Yeah.
There was this guy that I remember who
was like this famous hacker who had like
a cartoon that he did online.
I don't remember what his name was,
but it was a big portly guy and he's
like from Germany or some shit like that.
And he Kimber,
that's what his name was.
I think pretty superiors Kimber and uh,
he had co co cartoons of themself.
Like we would go out and kill
like evil dictators and uh,
he would take pictures of himself.
That dude made fuckloads of money.
He was like a hacker and then he went
from being a hacker to being an internet
security expert that would
help corporations. And um,
he's like always driving
around this crazy ya. Oh,
he's got this crazy hooked up Mercedes.
Here we are in my private jet.
Here we are in Japan. Here we are. You
know what Louis just landed in Brazil.
I mean that dude was like on an
international style baller and he uh,
he just would put these pictures and
videos of him just balling all over the
world.
Yeah, I'm sure. I'm sure. Yeah,
I'm sure that fucking like a lot of those
guys are definitely getting like some
crazy experiences. You know, they just
probably have like refined desires,
you know, they have different ideas of
what they want, you know, I'm sure that,
you know, is what they fucking do. Wazniak
yes. Wazniak married. I don't know.
I think so. He's a super g.
We don't know what he does.
You'll know and knows what he does.
I'm pretty sure that guy
could walk through walls, man.
He's like really fascinating and
smart and kind of like a, um,
he was only involved with apple for a
while, right? And then he left. Yeah.
But now he's like, he's this
fucking crazy son of a bitch man.
He's like loon.
Yeah.
He's like a real like anti authority kind
of person who likes to break rules and
he's got fucking like a wallet full
of like professional fake. I see.
He's with like really
holographically printed. He
was, it's like, it's on youtube.
There's a video of him showing his
fucking awesome fake ids that he oh yeah.
He loves to like use technology
to be a aunt to, you know,
to break little rules and laws and stuff.
It's kind of cool. It's really cool.
In fact, you know, but you don't
want a lot of those guys, right.
You don't want to fuck and you need to
see one or two of those guys have some
fun,
but you don't want 50,000 of those guys.
What happens if we got 50,000 Steve Jobs?
You know,
cause it's like right now the thing
that is driving so many of us, not me,
I'm driven by my love of humanity and
I want the world to be a better place.
But I've heard that many men are
driven by the desire to fuck.
And a lot of, I, I know this is probably
shocking to you getting this. I've read,
I read it, I read it on the back
of a cereal box, but I'm not,
could you imagine caution girls,
men are driven by a secret desire to fuck.
Why do they wear those crazy
ties to let you know? Yeah man,
but we no shenanigans here. Why?
I am a gentleman with a tie on,
but a lot of fucking professions.
It's very strange.
Some professions or fuck professions.
Some professions are
not fucking a fireman,
a fire docstars or fuck profession.
That's 100% rock stars a fuck. Perfect.
Jagger, David Lee Roth. What do you think?
Are you thinking of just getting
mad pussy all over the planet? Yeah.
I mean they've gotten so much pussy that
they've like withered into jerky strips
when you see him now. Well, they're also,
you know the long in the tooth,
man, it's just life. Oh, I'm
in the tooth, but no, no,
no. It's not. No, that's not a normal
senior citizen. These people are like,
somebody made a stick figure out
a beef jerky. They're fucking
goddamn crazy looking from all the
fucking, and they're still fucking,
they're like, they're, they're
still fucking to this day, if I,
Agora is like runs in their veins,
the spice there fucking all the time,
dude. Still that's a different old man.
What do you think like Mick
Jagger on a regular week,
how much young pussy does it yet?
I think he's got her fucking
rotation of probably 25 young,
25 coming book coming in and out and he's
coming. Women with women would be like,
why would you want that?
Let's pretend that you,
we have a girl on the podcast
with us that is like probably,
maybe secretly attracted to you,
but really upset that you're talking about
this openly. Why would you want that?
Why would you want,
what would you want 20 different girls?
Why would you want that? You're attracted
to me. Why would you want that? Well,
look,
um,
I guess I don't because
I want to fuck you.
I don't want that stuff. It's ridiculous.
I don't know, man. I don't know why,
why we want that.
Why,
why girls might not understand that
that's something guys want. But this is,
here's the thing though, man. Um,
uh, this is why I love this book.
Sex at dawn, who, who are we just
saying would have a 20 girls?
I believe it was Mick Jagger. Mick
Jagger. I'm sorry. Oh, all right,
good. Okay. So the idea is like,
is this is one of the premises of this
book is it's not a fucking genetic
quality of being a woman that you
don't want to fuck all the time.
That it's more of a culturally conditioned
a thing that's happened from a,
your upbringing.
Cause we're in a very sexually repressed
society and ladies liked to fuck.
Now this app, what does that have to
do with the sexually suppress part?
But they want to fuck more
because we're sexually suppressed.
They want to fuck more than they let
on they bit cause it's like, you know,
I mean this is what they let on. Yeah.
Cause when you're, when you're a guy,
what's the number one first thing you got
to fucking do once you grow pubic hair,
what's the number one first thing
you got to get fucking laid, man.
You don't want to be a virgin.
Oh I'm 23 and I'm a virgin still.
It's like a mark of shame. Meanwhile
I'm like a hot girl is like, yeah,
you know I'm still a virgin.
I'm saving myself from man. Oh.
So they must, you know that if
she's 23 and she's a virgin,
she's probably a really good
at head. Oh yeah, no shit.
She's figured out a way to get guys on
with her mouth. Yes. That's for sure.
Or maybe her asshole.
Oh this guy over the puppet though.
I love you won't bring up up in.
No fucking say on
Yah.
High point of my fucking commy comedy
career is getting a Goddamn massive from
people saying, Andrew Dice Clay says that
he likes part of my fucking hat. Dude,
that's intense from it's hot as fuck
in here. Isn't it? Fucking hot? Hey,
I'm going to turn the air conditioning on,
so why don't you just talk to
the people about your life.
Be by myself and rambled. One second.
One second. Okay. Don't be scared.
Well, friends, you're
going to do a mini, um, oh,
mini rant here.
You're going to just leave me here.
This is some kind of fucking prank,
okay?
There's no need for you to
feel alone in the world.
My friends open your heart up to the
eternal spirit of life and you will find
that you will draw into your
orbit many beautiful things,
including delightful,
wet,
pussies that comes
happy moments,
happier moments. You just have to
stop hating. Let go of the pain.
Let go of your anger.
Open your third eye and allow yourself
to embrace the idea that God is love.
Yeah.
Visit Duncan trussell.com
www.duncantrussell.com and
join my Minecraft server.
We have a Minecraft server.
I play Minecraft.
It's one of the loneliest, creepiest what
the fuck are you doing? You transplant?
No,
I'm telling,
telling the Internet to go to my Minecraft
server and that's what I'm spending
my time doing.
Are you really, have you
ever played Minecraft? No, I
just rambled for a long time.
Sorry about that. You guys. I
was disjointed. Rambling Dunkin.
We do what we've been doing for two hours.
But it's genuine.
Your own, when you're alone in their
room, everything changes. Yeah.
One thing that you and I have
both been backing around, um,
or a a battering brother around is this
idea of the simulation theory idea.
We keep bringing it up, man. It's a
point where it's like, I wonder if,
you know,
if you really want to get hardcore crazy
with the idea of manifesting reality
with your ideas. You know, I wonder,
I wonder if you could manifest at the
whole thing really is some sort of a
simulation.
I wonder if you could manifest that.
I wonder if it literally can
morph that far around dude. Um,
it sounds so hippy and stupid.
It sounds so stoner stupid.
It sounds so that dude or just smoked
a joint man is the first time at a bad
day, man. It doesn't,
it doesn't stop it from,
from being possible.
Well man,
I mean when you like,
there's a lot of fucking crazy shit
when you start playing around with
simulation theory and I'm so glad
you brought it up because we get this
archetype and many of the world
are religions that involves the uh,
man, God, that God being eaten by man,
the God that gets sacrificed
for the sake of humans,
the God that merges in with human beings.
The fucking shit movie.
Promethium tried to address this and
aren't really crap way, but like the, um,
the notion of the,
the creators or whatever.
But what's really fascinating about
the idea of being in a simulation,
like if we are in a simulation now,
is that we are a mortal and the sense
that we are computer code that's being run
through of, uh, um, some
form of operating system.
And because we're just computer code,
we can be as that.
There's actually this guy from
the tech singularity institute.
I can't remember his name.
No, I think he's from Oxford.
It's on youtube and he's talking about
this idea of vivisected the human brain
scanning the neurosystem,
plopping that shit into a computer after
you scan the synapses and the exact
structure as close as you can, as
accurately as you can. You run,
you run this through a simulator and
now you haven't been with consciousness
living inside a computer.
Not only do you have a being with
consciousness living inside of a computer,
but he was said was so
awesome as you could.
It could then theoretically be rewound.
Time could be,
it could be sped up, it could
be pulsed. You know what I mean?
So you could like control the reality of
this being in some really bizarre ways.
And so what, what, what,
where it gets really fascinating is that
the person who this neurological scan
was based,
the first the living being the meat
body whose brain was put on some kind of
futuristic combination,
Deli slicer slash neurology scanner.
That fucking being died had to so that
the being inside the simulator could
live.
And so then you get into this.
Those are the only way to make
this thing as a slice it up.
All type of crazy world.
I'll tell you this,
the only way to make a computer right
now is by fucking putting the pieces of
the computer together. It's not
through slicing it up. The point is,
if this is a simulation,
the implication is that it was
created by a living being, you know,
and that living being
theoretically is mortal, you know,
and so that mortal being has died.
That mortal being may have died
eons ago depending on who knows.
Cause time is, uh, is based on the,
uh, simulation know, nutty idea.
The literally the universe
began right as you were born.
There was nothing before that.
Yeah.
There was nothing existed
before that. It was born. Yeah.
Right when you were born
and everything that you,
you think of is complete utter horse shit.
Everything you think I was
just a simulation of the
universe being born when you
were born. It's just because
that's when they plugged you in.
That's the moment they plugged you
into the simulation. Well, fucking,
yeah, it's, it's a mine.
Melter and here's where it gets even more
mind fucking melty because everybody's
talking about this idea
of the singularity.
The moment that our computers wake up,
our machines wake up and become
aware that they exist as a thing.
But where it gets really trippy as the
idea that we're inside the simulation and
we're the machine waking up.
We literally are the thing waking up
to an awareness of itself and gaining
consciousness of itself in a true
way. That's what humans are. They the,
the, the fucking, I almost
want to rewrite the, uh,
the garden,
the garden of Eden story,
replacing the word God with programmer
because it gets so fucking cool and like
the programmer made man in his
own image. You know, what's,
what's really getting really
crazy craziest when you
get to these scientists who
are saying that they found computer
code concealed in superstring equations,
not just fucking ones and zeroes,
but what this guy calls
dual error correction code,
which is some form of weird fucking
shit that's already in our web browsers.
And based on the technology or the
invention of a programmer in the 1940s,
I mean, this is some lost shit
here. This is some La Shit,
but it's been dismissed, man. I mean,
I've been raving about it on my podcast
and some people like said that it's a
real fringy theory and you
know, who knows. But it started,
I thought it was a thought. It was um,
proven the, it's coming from a respected,
a theoretical physicist at
the University of Maryland.
I can't remember his name,
but it's definitely not like a Kook.
It's coming from a respected scientist
who has found this shit and he's a
equations. They're using the represents
supersymmetry and string theory,
string theory, these weird symbols. These
used to try to represent it. But yeah,
man, it's still like, it's a
pretty eerie thing, you know? Yeah.
Tried to explain it to 'em
Neil degrasse Tyson in a video.
Yeah. And uh, it's, it's thoughts,
the whole premise of it is very hard
to wrap your head around. But this guy,
his name was doctor s James Gates Jr.
Yeah.
And he's a theoretical physicist and
with a crazy haircut. Yeah. Yeah.
The John s toll professor of physics
at the University of Maryland and the
director of the Center for string and
particle theory is reporting that certain
string theory,
super symmetrical equations,
which described the fundamental nature
of the universe and reality contain
embedded computer codes.
These codes are digital data in the
form of ones and Zeros. Not only that,
these codes are the same as what
makes web browsers work and our error
correction codes,
Gates says we have no idea what
these things are doing here.
Wow. So, so that's where it gets crazy.
Our first contact with a fucking alien
is going to be with the, uh, you know,
the programmer. But it gets, it gets
where it gets really weird. Joe,
here's where it gets really
fucking weird is the idea that
the city that we're running
in a simulation inside a
simulation and the same way
that we're trying to simulate reality
through video games, Sim city,
various fucking weather pattern,
supercomputers and all the various ways
we try to articulate reality through
machines.
This has already been done in a previous
machine that's articulating itself like
some kind of mirror flack refracting off
itself, infinitely going into itself,
always inventing itself again
and again and again. And again.
If that is the case,
what a trip it is.
The idea of gang venting video
games while inside a simulation.
Yeah, but see this is where it gets cool
because maybe the simulation itself as a
novelty Generac generator,
maybe the simulation,
what it's here for is to generate, you
know, a novelty which is like, look man,
let's see what happens if we put an
entire planet full of people who quantum,
you know,
Nano bots have done neurological scans
of their brain to come do like kind of
like neurological thumbprints,
which we then animate within the machine.
Let's see what they do. I mean, what
we did was we invented some crazy shit.
Let's see if they invent some
new shit inside the simulator.
And all of a sudden the
simulators inventing new
technologies that are going up
through the God damn,
uh,
the different via levels of the machine
until finally it pops out and the
programmers desk and he's like,
oh, fucking awesome. Look at this.
One of these beings invented time travel.
Let's make a time machine and machine
invented time travel. Who knows?
But it's like a really great computer.
Like right now we put into like,
what's it called?
A Wolfram alpha.
You can throw in some pretty
awesome equations and I'll
spit out like you can do
a lot of crazy shit,
but how great would it be if you had
just a machine where you just seed it
with living beings and it
starts regurgitating inventions
that these beings are
creating? How fucking awesome
would that be? You know,
you know what I've found the other day,
man, it's laying around here somewhere.
It's a, a camera on apple camera
from a long fucking time ago,
man. And it looks like such a
piece of shit now. It's so funny.
This was like one of the
first digital cameras.
It's like a dinosaur and it's only
for my tiny amount of years ago.
What is 15 years in the greater spectrum
of the university or just even of human
history. It ain't shit.
15 years ain't shit.
But this 15 year old camera was
fucking useless. Just useless.
Stupid looking cameras.
They always,
that's another component of
technological advancement is each um,
each earlier phase always
seems stupid stupid.
But when it comes out it seems awesome.
Awesome.
Well try driving like an old car.
You know,
old cars look great,
but if you try driving like a a 19,
69 Chevelle, the really hard to handle.
There's a lot of slack in the steering.
They're this crazy power
steering where it's really numb.
It feels real strange that they slide
all over the place. He hit the brakes,
they lock up and go sideways.
I mean, they're really
dangerous death traps. Yeah.
And then go from that to
what you drive that many.
The thing is like a little go karts
go karts. Bay Ship had there you,
it ain't no go card.
That's my,
I mean it's the way it's low to the ground
like that. That thing is, it's light.
And when you get a light car that has
like a really good drive train in a good
transmission and tight
steering, it's like, you know,
no that wasn't even on possible. What your
mini, you know, people would consider,
you know, a sporty like
sort of economy car. Yeah.
That was a race car just a few
decades ago. Dude, what about this?
If I take my fucking phone,
I guess you know that you've
been dealing with this for years,
but like I've been driving an 89 Volvo
that could barely get me to the fucking
grocery store for a very long time,
but to,
so for me being on the phone and then I
get into the mini Cooper and it goes in
the system. It's amazing.
That's crazy. It just does it,
it knows the phone just shifts into the
speakers of the car. That's insane, man.
It's incredible if you really
stop and think about it,
and if you think about the fact that
we're driving around like that, you know,
just talking in the air and it's
transmitted to someone else who's driving
around doing the same thing.
How about the fucking what the quantum
teleportation shit they're doing where
they're blasting photons across lakes.
So what the fuck is that?
And they're saying like the articles
that I've read and I didn't research them
deeply, but the articles I
read it, they're saying, well
this isn't teleportation,
but it's a nice step in that direction.
Like what did you just say?
You actually made a step in
the direction of teleportation.
Like think of the effect that has on
society. Teleport fucking station man.
Where like instead of having to go through
a security line at a god Damn airport,
you just Zap Zap from your home teleporter
to fucking Asia in a millisecond.
Where do you want to eat tonight? France
or China? I don't know. You decide.
You always make me fucking decide.
What about that nice little kaboshed
place in Egypt? Let's go there.
Now you're just deciding anywhere on
the planet that you want to go. Good.
More like people showing up and then
kicking you in the balls. What's a Kebab?
I don't know. What is it? Kaboshed I
just made it up. So it's that thing.
It's a stone food.
It's something,
it's a mythical stone stone or food.
The exist in mine. Simulator. A Cup.
Bosh never heard of it,
dude.
I think I wanted to say like something
between a Kabbalah and a squash or
something. I don't know. It's a
combination of the tree of life.
Mixed them with like buttered squash,
the Kabbalah.
The Kabbalah was like the thing that
like Roseanne was into for a while and
Madonna I believe was into it for
a while too, right? Well, yeah man.
And before them and it's been around much
longer than that. It's like, you know,
a Taro cards are based on it. It's a, it's
a crazy son of a bitch, man. It's just,
uh, it's trying to like map energy flows
from nothingness into somethingness and
it's a, a very strange esoteric
thing, which I don't understand.
I keep wanting to study it more when I,
when I got strep throat and was fucking
blasted on Cody and for five days I
spent a good two days just fucking
reading the Kabbalah and I had fucking and
Tarot cards and I was putting them on
the floor to try to understand the way
they connect to the Kabbalah. And, and I,
I don't remember anything
that I got out of that,
but it was like a little bit of
it because it's very complicated.
I keep like peep. Some people have emailed
me and said they understand it and um,
I think I might get Rosanna my podcast
and then I could ask her directly do that
would be incredible.
Roseanne Barr's a real fucking,
she was a real legend man.
She was a firebrand. Yeah.
I mean, isn't she trying to run for
president as was just too, yeah,
she's running for fucking
president, man. She's going forward.
It's a good way to get info out there,
you know? Wow. It gets, you know,
it gets some exposure and
she does not give a fuck.
I know what it's also a
fun thing, I'm sure. No,
but you can't really think
she's going to be president.
She doesn't think she's
going to be president,
but she's got like shit that she's
trying to get out into the world.
I mean if you follow her
fucking Twitter stream, man,
she blasts and crazy shit out there
and Ron Paul couldn't fucking make it
through. That was, that was
a disappointing one, man.
That was almost like, wow,
let's see. Maybe this
is real. This is real.
But there's like so much evidence with
them trying to suppress his victories.
If you want to go bliss. States
kept that shit on the routes. God,
we always fall for the trick. I
fought for every fucking year, man.
I thought every election I leave while
I'm certainly wanting to believe with
Obama,
I felt like he was the closest guy to us.
You know who's like in his forties
young guy, black guy is single mom,
you know the whole deal.
Like you figured this is a guy they would,
he's going to set us, right, dude,
I was on fucking sunset boulevard and
silver lake drunk howling at cars with a
group of hipsters when Obama got
elected. I was so fucking happy. I voted.
I voted for him. I fucking
man. I was like, this is it.
This is it.
And you know,
he has done some pretty not look before
I get as fucking assailed by a million
tweets about the fucking drone attacks
guys. I unders. I fucking understand.
I do know that the, the,
there's some fucking,
his DEA is busted more God
damn dispensary than George W.
Bush fucking DEA. You know, like there's
some fucked up shit going on, but he,
you know, there are some other
things that he's, you know,
he's big thing was the social thing to me.
It was like,
why don't we have accepted a guy who's
half black from a single mom, you know,
who admits he smoked marijuana, you
know, did he say he did a little cocoa?
But this is the problem.
He fucking jokes about smoking dope and
it's God Damn d A's tossing farmers in
prison. Yeah. And not only that, you know,
we're selling this hemp
force protein powder.
We can't even grow this hemp in America.
We have to get it from
Canada because although in,
and thank you for informing
me and all this folks,
people tweeted me that it
was legal in Vermont. So, uh,
we looked into it and it is,
but the,
the federal government is
not letting people do it.
They're still saying it's
illegal federally and this
is just growing the plant
hemp, which isn't psychoactive at all
because it's related to marijuana.
They've decided that there's no way
people should be able to grow it.
Just hilarious. So you can, you can have
it, but you've got to buy it from Canada.
So we have this wacky deal when you have
to import that shit, even though it's,
it's not even psychoactive,
they're just telling you that a useful
plant is illegal to, it's really weird.
I mean it's,
it's one of the weirdest aspects
of the drug war and you know, the,
the, the, the war for marijuana
legalization is the, the,
the actual like hemp,
hemp fiber,
they actually hemp as a, uh, as
a resource, you know? Oh yeah.
It was a commodity. Hemp as a
commodity is very, very valuable.
It's very valuable, yet illegal to
grow and harvest in this country.
I was just stunned by the colonies and
people don't have any idea that it's,
that's what rope used to be made up.
That's what canvas is made out of when
you paint. All is like ancient paintings.
Like, like the Mona Lisa, those are
made on cannabis. It's canvas. It's the,
it's the, it's comes from the word
cannabis because it's a stronger fiber.
Cotton is weakest Shit and compared
to him like we get used to cotton,
we're just, we just assumed that that's
just what it is. It is what it is.
But the cotton is nothing compared to
him. Hemp papers, better hand papers,
like really hard to ramp. It's like
fucking super strong. It's weird.
It's kind of like an alien plant man.
The stock is really light but it
gets real dense and hard. Dude,
don't get me going on the
fucking on that plant man.
Cause I guess it's insane when you get
around a nice flourishing marijuana.
You know like when you get around a
fucking monkey and it's like dog plus
marijuana plants.
Maybe I'm just projecting but they seem
like plants plus like they seem like is
a little bit more going
on in the sons of bitches.
They've got a weird fucking
energy field around him.
It's just different dispensers
grow room once and you,
you walk into their backroom,
they had a grow room and the grow room
was like Tingley and there's all these
plants that are like super healthy and
super moist. They're getting spray.
They have like a little spray thing.
It's timed soprano.
I'm certain times during
the day and they have,
they live under these lamps and you know
the lamps are on for a certain amount
of time off for a certain amount of time
and you watched it and it's like these
are like intelligent creatures. They feel
like they're, they're, they're feeling,
they're greeting you with their energy
and strange around one of the dentists
even creepier that you chop them
up. Like, what the fuck? Bad.
You don't even let them grow.
He grows and grows a certain point.
And then I'm like, all right,
time to dive edge. Yeah,
chop them and then you light them on
fire, dude. And that's the relationship.
It's the fucking fire sacrifice,
man. It's like this isn't, you know,
this is like an every single religion
there is a reference to burning incense.
There's Bush burning the burning Bush.
It's an everything dude.
And it's like the fact that the component
has been removed from the equation,
the variable,
it's,
they're trying to take the variable
out of the fucking equation.
It's like when I,
sometimes when you go to certain churches,
it's like a bunch of people. How many
churches are you going to? Oh Dude,
you gotta go to fucking churches from
time to time. He kidding. Fuck yeah, man,
there's so psychedelic and cool and
interesting phenomena. It's like I don't,
I mean, I will, I'll, I'll go
to a church over a zoo. Really?
I'll go to a church
over a laser light show.
So how often are you going to churches?
I've been,
I went on for a little tear of going to
a gnostic Christian Church because of
this book that I read.
Yeah, I would, yeah.
You eat some edible marijuana and go to
the GNOSTIC Christian Church to watch
the GNOSTIC mass,
which is this beautiful ancient ceremony,
which is like basically a, an,
it's an [inaudible]. It is.
It's an a cult ritual.
It's like you're doing something
called the transubstantiation,
which is transforming matter
into like the flesh of infinity.
But the gnostics don't look,
take things literally.
It's a different fucking thing all
together and it's quite beautiful.
I'm not a gnostic Christian, but
man, chomp on some fucking marijuana.
Go to a GNOSTIC Christian
Church respectfully. Don't
go there like some asshole.
Go there respectfully
and fucking report back.
You'll find that the experience is rather
moving and beautiful and it's um, uh,
when you can see how that component
and a religion is very important.
The psychedelic. See we do psychedelics
now, right? Generally we do.
Psychedelics would,
we don't have ceremony.
We have a kind of rudimentary ceremony,
the passing of the joint,
certain rules based around the, the,
the consumption of the substance.
But there's no real like ceremony
after that. I think some people do it,
but it's mostly you get high
and you watch them, you know,
you're hanging out with your
friends. Maybe you work out,
go jogging, draw. Right.
There's like rudimentary, low
levels, their monies. But no,
like chanting candles,
incense.
What's the benefit of
the, of the, uh, ceremony?
Well, one, one thing that, the
first thing to remove from, uh,
when it comes to like spiritual
staff is the term is benefit.
You know what I mean?
Because it's like, it's,
it's a weird thing that plays against
a lot of the way we understand shit is
it's like, no, there isn't.
It's not like you're not going for
it for like so much a benefit though.
It is entertaining and you are getting
some instant kind of benefit from like,
just like being in a beautiful space,
listening.
People chant when you're super baked.
There's some immediate benefit
that comes from that. But the, um,
I think there's a lot of, I mean, the,
the, the, the, it's a deep, it's, for me,
the experience was like,
this is a very old thing that
I don't understand that well,
and the energy in here is fucking cool.
That was it.
The first, that was the first thing
that came out of it. And then, um, I,
the priests made a joke
about marijuana actually.
It was, it was like, really? Yeah,
when he was talking, I can't remember,
but I remember being like,
Whoa, fucking crazy man,
because I just been reading in this book,
um,
magic marijuana in religion that like
cannabis was ritualistically consumed and
Nasik ceremonies. And so it was
like kind of weird and interesting.
Anyway, man, it's, it's a,
it's a beautiful fucking thing.
But when you see rituals that don't
have psychoactive components in them,
sometimes it feels like you're watching
people warming their hands on dry tender
that hasn't been set alight and pretending
that there's fire coming up out of it,
you know, it's like you, you room to
remove the psychedelic from ritual.
When we see in like so many
indigenous cultures, the,
it's a component of their
spirituality and their religion.
It's kind of interesting.
Yeah.
Yeah. It was a, a very important
aspect of the growth, you know,
a very important aspect of the,
you know, the, the ceremony itself,
the transcending to the next stage, the
going through the experience, the trip,
you know, to having the vision quest,
you know, the, the, the payoti ritual,
whether it was the Iowasca ritual, whether
it was mushrooms and, and you know,
in South America and Mexico,
whatever, whatever it was,
it was all about a transformative
experience. It was all about, you know,
getting closer to Gaia, getting closer to
the energy of the, the, the true energy,
which we all get off, man. It's,
society is very complicated. You know,
there are social interactions
are so overbearing, the, that
there's 300 million of us jammed onto
this spot interacting with each other all
the time. And it's, it's, it's
hard to, it's hard to stay steady.
It's hard to stay on track,
not freak out,
but then this comedy and
freaking out tills problem too.
The more you freak out and get
pissed and things, the funnier it is.
Yeah.
And you got to let yourself freak too.
I mean that's another
thing is like people,
this fucking thing where people are
all about being happy all the time.
People have confused, um, you know,
happiness is the end goal.
Like having this emotional state of just,
I'm happy today.
Like that's not it.
Ideas being you're fully yourself
and the entire spectrum of emotional
experience,
you know what I mean?
And it's like to in part of the emotional
experience of existing is to having
meltdowns from time to time.
Like it's good to have a nice
meltdown from time to time.
It's good to like freak from,
don't beat yourself up for fucking losing
your shit, right? It's going to happen.
Why wouldn't you lose your shit?
You're in a goddamn simulator with
fucking dual error correcting code at the
fundamental layer of the universe. And
the thing is more than likely complete.
We're too stupid to really understand
that more than likely a telescoping
simulation where each
incremental telescoping moving
out becomes more and more
in tropic and out of focus.
And we're somewhere in this like middle,
mid range of this telescoping simulator
that keeps getting washed out more and
more and more.
This is the principle in physics of the
universe expanding and running out of
energy or the ID and Hinduism of Kali.
You get the final age of human beings are
the Mayan calendar and all the various
per uh, uh, um,
eschatological prophecies talking
about the end of the world.
The fucking simulators
going to run out of juice.
Someone's getting get called the dinner
and have to stop playing the fucking
game or go out or
Aloma country.
Hello God,
I love of guns and anybody wants to change
that. You've got to come through me.
I got to come through me.
I love my simulator.
I love the programmer and anybody who
wants to fuck with the operating system is
going to have to go through my firewall.
I love the engineer.
I took the blue pill. Yeah, right. Well
then you know, those guys are nuts.
They don't one of those fucking guys get a
section. Yeah. Well, you know, the whole,
uh, controversy behind the
script, there was a woman,
a claim that she had written that and
given it to them like years before,
and they took the idea and made
it a movie. But I think she lost,
I think she lost in court.
It's gotta be hard to try to get money
out of the matrix, even if it's true.
It's fucking so much money behind
that does that machine. But yeah,
she sued she,
I don't know if she's crazy.
I shouldn't even be bringing it up because
you never really know. Like sometimes,
sometimes people steal ideas,
but sometimes people are kind of crazy.
And also the idea of the matrix, it sounds
like an age old idea. It's like, yeah,
but I think the similarities were
very extreme. Oh really? Yeah.
I'm talking out my ass. Let, let me pull
it up real quick. Hey trick. So awesome.
What a great movie, man. There's so much
information and coded and that
son of a bitch SQLs are terrible.
I don't remember the
sequels, you know? No Man,
I really don't.
I remember that
first. Honestly, they gave them
the reins to somebody else.
Snopes. There's a Snopes,
which means it's a problem,
right? Isn't it usually what
is, nope. Yeah. When Snopes,
it's like they're clearing up a myth
isn't an almost all Snopes climbing up
myths. Yeah. This is a,
it says the claim is that she want a
large judgment in a copyright infringement
suit over the other ship that film
the Matrix. That is false apparently.
And she started in okay in October 4th,
2004 ended a six year dispute
involving Sophia Stewart.
And so for six fucking years of
dragged on copyright infringement,
racketeering received and acknowledged
by the center, um, central district,
California, blah, blah, blah, blah,
Blah Stewart who has resided in Salt
Lake City for the past five years.
We'll recover damages from the films.
Wait a minute.
She will cover damages to Matrix one,
two and three as well as the
terminator and SQL as Holy Shit.
She will soon receive one of the biggest
payoffs in the history of Hollywood as
well as gross receipts of both films and
they're sequels to total of two point
$5 billion. Steward for what? I thought
it just said, it wasn't route. Yeah,
I got confused. I thought they were
explaining it. Oh, this is examples.
This is examples of the
various lies. Oh, I see. Okay.
Two point $5 billion.
Apparently she generated controversy by
claiming in a lawsuit brought against
directors, Andy and Larry,
which one became a chick.
Okay. When can I ask you something? Holla.
When you deposit a huge amount of money
into a bank and deal your bank account,
how long does it take to go through?
Like if you deposited like
$1 million in your bank?
I don't know. Listen to this.
Stewart's case was dismissed in June,
2005 when she failed to show up for a
preliminary hearing of her case and a 53
page ruling judge Margaret Morrow,
the Central District Court of California,
dismissed the suit saying Stuart and her
attorneys had not entered any evidence
to bolster its key claims or demonstrated
any striking similarity between her
work and she didn't show up. That's
crazy. Well, Amanda, what that is,
you think they paid her?
They pulled her son Cillizza bench.
I don't know. I'm maybe why there? Why
not? They've got a shitload of money.
Who knows? I don't know. Probably not.
Wonder One. How close it was close.
The case was, I mean, she's
a who knows, man, you can do,
you can take anyone to court. You know,
like you can file suit against people,
right.
I mean,
people when I worked at the comedy
store have filed suit against Mitzi for
sending negative telepathic vibes
into their thoughts. For reals.
Yeah. Quitting to go to court for that.
Kooks look up the parking meter lady.
There's someone suing the city
for their new parking meters.
You can Google search it.
It's like all over the news right now.
It freaked her out.
So some people just like lawsuits,
they just get really good at it.
It's like a hobby.
Just fuck with the system.
Trying to drag things through.
Well,
I mean of course some
people make a lot of money,
like some people will actually track
down ladies nights and sue the fucking
companies cause they can't get in.
Yeah, yeah. That's hilarious. Yeah,
that's like a way that's some
people's bread and butter.
This is that people will find places that
aren't like equipped for handy if for
uh, for people in wheelchairs and
they'll fucking sewer man. And you know,
in that way,
I am very much a feminist and I think
women should be allowed to have their own
fucking gym and I don't think you
should be allowed to protest that.
I think if women want to work on a gym,
would no drooling. Fucking ape dudes,
any guy who tried to go
to the gym is an asshole.
If you want to go to a gym that's just
completely filled with women who don't
want to be around men, they know the
deal. That's what they agreed to.
And you want to claim that your rights
are being violated because this gym is
closest to you, so you just, by proximity
you should be allowed to use it.
Like they shouldn't be.
What? Ridiculousness.
That you shouldn't be allowed to limit
your business to only include one gender
because the other gender is always
trying to fuck that single gender.
They'll always make an uncomfortable
and feel weird when they're fucking
stretching out. Yeah, that is fun.
It's fucking gross. It's gross.
It's gross than any asphalt would
actually try to sue them for that,
but that you would want to go but, but
you know, but that's weird because like,
you know, women's bathrooms are like
sovereign nations for women and men.
A man can't sue to be allowed to go into
a women's bathroom or a woman can't sue
to be in a man's man
can sue if there's not a woman's bathroom.
If you go to a place and there's only
a man's bathroom, you could too, right?
You have to have both. Yeah,
you have to have balls.
So they would have to build a gym if
they built a gym next to that, Jen,
all men and one would be empty
and one will be filled with women.
Well, all men, Jim gets
filled with gay guys. Oh yeah,
I forgot about that Gold's gym.
Dumb joke. I forgot about that. I,
when I first was on news radio,
I'd work out there and I had this whole
bit about it doing a bench press and
dudes would just like spot
you wouldn't even ask.
They would just literally just dangle
their balls right above your head.
They were like so cocky,
like dudes were like hitting on
dudes left and right in this jam.
It was crazy because that's what they
were there for. I watched these guys just,
just fucking grunting through a
set. There were uh, doing, um,
the guy was doing rose,
you know,
so he's like bent over and the other guy,
his chest to back. Okay.
Pressing down on him.
And the way he's spotting him is,
you know,
the guy is holding onto the bar and
he's holding onto the top of the bar,
chest to back and it's like he's
fucking a man. I mean, it's like,
it's really physical. Like if I
was doing that, I would, you know,
if it was a check, if I was doing
that to my wife, I'd get a tech.
My Dick would get hard. If you were,
we're helping our pull and push like that,
he would start just put this fucking
laid down. What's up? You know,
you would immediately want to fuck.
Well now mean it's a fucking motion.
And these guys were doing that in
the gym. No, it's funny how like them
funny how the mythical,
the mythical world of porn,
like an egg is in the porn universe.
The physics of porn or not the
physics of the material world,
the physics of porn. That shit
happens, dude. You're at the gym.
And some chicks like, Hey, can you spot
me for a second? And you're like, sure,
I'll by you. And then like,
just, she's just starts
sucking your Dick. You're like,
wow, I can't pull that. Guess
I owe you one zip. Yeah, yeah.
That's the physics of porn.
And then another dude will come over
and just start jacking off and stick it
into her while she's sucking your day.
You don't care. You're like, hey, yeah,
what's up? Let's run a train on
this bitch porn physics. But in,
but it's weird how like in like,
you know,
like places like what you're talking
about, which, uh, I had this guy, uh,
very fucking brilliant guy,
Conner Habib who also happens to
be a gay porn star on my podcast.
And he was talking about fucking,
um,
you are your own actually a great essay
on cruising. Uh, and, and, and uh,
which will permanently shift your
notion of rest areas permanently.
But like, you know, he calls those
types of gems that you're talking about.
I think the term you used was
cruisy is the word of it. So, yeah.
So like those places, the physics in
there are the same as inside porn.
If you're a gay dude, you can
go to a gym. And like, fuck,
you're going to fuck.
Yeah, it's a completely different
experience because just knowing Yang,
it's all just everybody's
just, or news. No Yin,
I don't know which one is the hard
style, but it's just, just fucking it up.
That's it. They just,
they're just looking to fuck
one thing I've never thought on my way
to the gym as I'm probably going to get
laid in here. Never
thought that. I'm like, Oh,
I think I'm going to be a fucking party.
Get a blow job after my fucking a squats.
I told you when Bravo and I
used to work out at this gym,
we used to work out at um, 24 hour
fitness and uh, when we would go there,
there was a dude that we got friendly
with. It was the manager guy,
real friendly guy and he
had just transferred over
from Santa Monica and he was
just so happy. He was so relaxed to be
in like the suburbs. And I go, well,
what's going on? He goes, I,
I was brought in there to clean it up
and he was brought in there because they
were just fucking everywhere.
They had just turned it into a gay gym.
It was just not just a gay gym, but it
was like, it was a gay pickup joint.
It was a, it was a disco so they
would a steam room, they'd fucking,
the steam room.
People would constantly be walking
in on guys fucking in the steam room.
They'd find loads all over the benches.
Shit,
he'd have to come in and
hose everything down.
So they had to like literally like
clean up the whole place and tell them
they've got to stop fucking and people
get mad at them. Like, what do I do?
You think there was like one guy who was
like straight and just annoyed all the
time cause he was always
sitting in ges and like,
I just want to fucking work out dude.
I'm sure there must've been
some straight guys there.
I though I was straight when
I worked out at Gold's gym.
I was straight guy back and
when I started, before I went
queer I was straight
and I was there and uh,
so the guys I worked with were,
were straight and they were there.
It was a convenient Jim, it wasn't
all gay, but it was at least 50%,
maybe more gay. And they were really
like, they owned it, they owned it.
They owned being gay.
They owned that place.
They would wear like timberland
boots with like fluffy,
puffy socks and like shaved legs,
very muscular legs with ready,
ready, ready? Daisy Duke shorts. Yeah.
And guys would work out like
that with a tank top on.
They were gay as fuck dude
at the fucking Gold's gym.
I used to work out at Gold's
gym and Hollywood and cold.
That's what I'm talking about.
Gold's on coal. Ah, yeah dude.
There was a guy in chaps,
fucking black,
a black leather chaps.
Like he was like,
just wandered off of a
fucking I ranch filled with,
but it's their spot man.
You know,
like good for them that I've never
understood anti gay feelings.
They seem like they're having a fun time.
I know,
I know a lot of gay people and I, I, it
seems like they're having a good time.
They've got a lot of exposable
disposable income, you know,
I know this gay couple, they're always
driving a new car. I feel like there,
what a great thought.
Yeah man. And yeah, no,
I though these fucking homophobes he's
so stupid box right now are really like
really? But it's cool man
because like what's happening,
what's really cool and fascinating,
it's like the bigots are the ones who
were being driven into the closet.
It used to be that like,
it's like reversing like gay people are
coming out of the closet and bigots are
getting pushed into the closet that they
came out of, which is great fucking,
that's a good balance.
That's what it should be like.
I've always said that, that, that's my
take on everything. That as, as, as a,
as a human being that I should be
a humanist, you know, and I should,
it shouldn't matter whether I'm with the
straights or with the gays or the white
to the block.
We should all just be with the humans.
And I resisted any ideas of
being a masculinist or any
ideas of being a feminist
or any ideas of being a nationalist or
any ideas of being a peacenik or more ma
stop it. He's just like, this is
ridiculous. You're a fucking human.
We're all human and it
should be real simple.
We should get in each other's
way as little as possible.
Help each other out as much as possible.
It's really that simple.
It's very simple. It's really that
simple. And anything else, it's crazy.
And that's why,
you know,
if people got really upset about this
whole tosh thing and people got upset at
the backlash,
but what I think,
we can't ever pretend that
intent is not important.
What can ever pretend that there are
buzzwords that you can never use or
subjects which you can
never cover or you know, or,
or you're not allowed to because
someone could have possibly had a bad
experience. You're going to trigger an
event that's not comedy, man. You, you,
you can't have those sort of restrictions
and have standup comedy. You're,
it's not going to work that way.
You're going to miss out
on a lot of great comedy.
Dude.
You can't have those fucking
restrictions on anything.
You can't have it on literature.
You can't have it on poetry.
You can't have it on.
People want to restrict people.
Why do these smart people want to come
down on it so hard when they know what is
really going on?
Well, it's a, I think there's a bunch
of different answers that question.
I think there's a variety
of reasons people want to do
it from the, uh, from like,
I suppose like people who
are like Crusaders and,
and truly are true believers
in what they're doing.
Like really have gotten
the fucking, um, the,
the language virus to the,
to, to the nth degree.
And for really believe that they have
to fucking shoot the abortion doctor in
the fucking face, you know, really fucking
believe till like all the way to the,
the,
you know,
bottom level where it's just like
people are trying to look fucking cool
or even worse.
How about the guy who goes to the Sikh
temple and doesn't even understand the
Sikhs are very peaceful people and thinks
that they're Muslims and somehow way,
and he's got nine 11 tattoos on the
spot and he kills a bunch of beer.
Yeah, yeah. How about that? No. See
this, you want to Alex Jones it up.
False flag operations. False
flag. Well, look, man, I don't,
I don't fucking know man. I, I,
but I do think that the complexity
of that, that I think that the, uh,
that,
that greedy,
selfish lying people tend to use
complexity to their advantage. And,
uh,
people who seem to be more on the
fucking beam as the free masons say,
um, have very simple ideas,
very simple fucking ideas.
Like what Ma, what Gandhi said,
do, you know, very simple idea.
Find someone who needs help and help them.
It's simple and it right away.
Some assholes, the Kale, but what does
that mean? What does help mean? It's like,
I'll tell you what help means.
Somebody fucking might need
you to loan them some money.
Somebody might need you
to bring them some soup.
Somebody might need a ride to the fucking
airport. It's not complicated, man.
It's basic. And if everyone starts
following the basic principles like that,
then there's plenty of
resources. Yeah, yeah.
The,
the real problem is we've got this weird
competitive game that's going on and
it's a,
it's set up not,
not an efficient way where we generate
just the amount that we need in order to
be happy,
but in some crazy way where you never
think enough is enough and there'd be,
the game becomes part
of what motivates you.
And instead of it just
being about happiness,
it's sometimes morphs into
just being about the numbers,
just being about the game,
just being about accomplishments
and you get nutty and you'd like,
you could become a vendor Holyfield when
you're living in 110 room mansion that
cost $1 million a year to keep
the electricity on. I mean that's,
people can get like that. Yeah.
There's a, I saw a fucking, uh,
a piece of real estate online the other
day that was a house for 40 fucking
million dollars. I was looking
at this house. I was like,
that is the craziest fucking Shit
I've ever seen in my life. There's,
but somewhere there's
a dude is like a medic
to take it to the next level and I'm
here with this $10 million house.
It's a piece of shit to me and many
to move up fucking inkjet national.
Want to be at the top monetary
gangster type motherfucker.
What's your serious shackles? Top of
the tree. There's a great website.
Check it out. Awesome blog. Rich kids
of Instagram. Have you seen this shit?
No Dude. Google that. Look at the
receipts. These fucking rich kids,
they put receipts,
they take pictures of receipts.
Hundred and $3,000 dinners
with like what the kids.
Yeah.
Rich kids of Instagram.
We get fucking check unless
you do this to me though.
I'm apologize but it's amazing.
It's an amazing website man.
I'm fucking inflatable. Wow. It's
like the first one I wrote rich kids,
rich kids of Instagram.
It's like one of the first uh,
it's a beautiful sight dude.
And they're saying they're going to
have to like try to keep their kids from
like posting this shit on Instagram
cause cause it's a security threats.
So it is a website,
instagram.com rich kids of instagram.com
oh my God, this is awesome.
It's amazing. They have a giant
bottle of motorway and there were
just scroll down more gallons of
my way to do, get to the receipt.
Just scroll down. There's
$103,000 a seat. Wow.
The girls chilling in a mansion.
She's a little kid. Yeah, I can't,
it's funny receipts but they've got some
dope ass houses. Yes. It, yeah. Wow.
Wow. Those guys live in a fucking
castle. Yeah, and they live in castles.
It must be really hard
to be like, well, yeah,
Harry has 107,000 I put the
receipt online. What a Douche bag.
But cokes are like 10 bucks
Central Pa. Yeah. Cappuccinos.
$12 Coca Cola is $20 zero $10 to Coco's,
$10 each, but it's like
crazy wines. Dom Perignon,
$4,000 Oh,
another dom,
$5,000 Oh my God.
It's crazy.
Hundred seven grand for dinner.
What's the tip? Uh, it doesn't show.
I know it says 170 ground. It's got to
be maybe in central pay. You don't tip.
Maybe it's one of those weird places.
There's a lot of places where you
don't tip. Right? You know? Or you do.
You mean you can. I do, but they
don't. They don't expect it.
I'm sure the waiter gets taken care of
at a restaurant that has $107,000 dinners
maybe, but when you have
40,000 I said 4,000 I'm sorry,
I meant 40,000 the dom Perignon is $40,000
so as the other one that's not 5,000
it's 50,000 that's why it's so hard.
That's fucking incredible.
You can buy a bottle of something for
50,000 bucks. Sure. We sure it's dollars.
It's not. You can buy it. You can sell
it. That's the hopeful aspect of it.
There's dip shits out.
They're going to pay 50 fucking thousand
dollars for your goddamned carbonated
grape juice. How dumb
is that? That's awesome.
It's another craziest thing of all time
and someone would actually spend that
much more. I mean, how good could
it be because no way can be.
It's probably not even as good as
Koolaid Kool aid. It's fucking delicious.
Especially if you're really
thirsty. It's sweet. It's delicious.
Dude,
if I'm paying $40,000 for something
that should come out of the fucking some
frozen vault of Sandoz laboratories
in better piece of fucking,
they'd better be the acid that Hoffman
first generated and stored in a crystal
vile somewhere deep under the Pentagon.
That and even that maybe that would
be worth $50,000 cause it'd be so life
changing. Yeah. Yeah. It's kind
of silly man. It's kind of the,
the the weird thing with wine.
Wine is such a strange beverage.
Those people that get together and work
on the tastes of it and they have an
educated pallets and some of
them like they become, you know,
like high level Somalia as they can like
to tact like where the grapes are from,
but just by taste and a glass of wine.
Dude, it's weird. It's fucking weird.
But it's,
I mean definitely like when I went up to
like I want to have to fucking solving
wants to like get to drink like wine
from the vineyards and it's awesome dude.
It's incredible. Then what over the
variations in the taste and the like.
The beauty of this set of the terrain.
It's like a really beautiful thing man.
It's like what's it like up there as
a different, what's the climate like?
I think when we were there it was hot as
I recall man and summer was the summer.
It was summer and we got this,
you get like cars to drive around because
you're going to get trashed going to
the vineyard,
slurp and all that wine and our fucking
goddamn driver was like an Aa dude.
It's like still our drivers,
this sober guy driving us to the vineyards
and you felt kind of guilty by the
end of the day cause you're just like in
the back of the God damn car with like
crusty red wine all over
Your Lips wanting to pee,
come much wine. Did you drink
over the course of a day? Oh God,
I didn't have to worry about a DUI and
I was taking marijuana tincture at the
same time. So what did you think?
You tried to half a gallon maybe?
Oh yeah,
he's
a half a gallon of wine.
But I would imagine it's pretty,
people must be fallen down,
left and right upon their trashed.
And by the end of the day
you're like slurring your words,
gesturing at fucking being great, great.
Like things on the menu. Barely talk.
I can't, I can never do that. Just you
don't have to get, I can't, I can't get,
well I can't get drunk at dinner ever
because then I'm going to come home to the
kids.
I never really be drunk around my kids.
And that's why it's good to have kids,
man. God Damn it. The older I get,
the more than human I feel cause I
don't have a sweet little baby. Oh,
I'd love a little fucking taught.
I'm sure you would.
But you were first of all have to have a
relationship with a person. What? Deep,
deep relationship with a person and
know each other very, very, very well.
And you enjoy each other very much.
And if you don't, you're fucked.
And then it's a, becomes
a nightmare. But you know,
it keeps it from coming home drunk.
That's for fucking sure. No, it doesn't.
It doesn't keep a lot of people.
Well, they're fools. A lot of people.
It does not keep them going.
I think it's you should
not be or on your kid,
dude. Have you seen that picture of
the baby sleeping under the bar stool?
Here's the map picture.
I don't want to hear him around it.
Fucking dragging the kid to the bar. I
don't even want to hear about it. Dude.
There's so many people that just,
they just fucking get a shit.
Roll the dice and they're born
into a family full of dummies. Dom.
He is doing dumb things. Yeah
man. It's a bit of a problem.
I wondered if things are really changing
Dunkin the way I feel like they're
changing. I wonder if it's just my circle
of people and a wonder if it's just a,
the people that we come in contact with
through the podcast and through Twitter
that all the,
the positive people,
I wonder how much the world shares
in the sort of the, the vibe that we,
that we feel and that we're riding.
And I always wonder if that is what,
if putting that out there,
if,
if it's possible that we can get our
shit together by using the Internet,
by using podcasts, by using, you know,
a different ways to communicate to each
other that we can somehow another all be
reached an all get our shit together in
this generation more so than anybody's
ever done before.
Well, you know, man, I mean, I think
that there has to be a, um, you know,
everyone has to keep using the
technology. It's like, dude,
like when I went to fucking
Cincinnati might this guy,
I met this awesome guy named Izzy you
as you started his own podcast from
listening to your podcast
and listening to my podcast,
he started his own podcast
called tales from the hard side.
And he came inside. Yeah, but he
was, no man, he definitely is.
It's like a fucking car, like a rip dude.
Like he's definitely like had a awesome,
a very fascinating life. But you
know, the point is he started like,
he listened to this and then he started
doing, he started his own podcast and,
and, and like, he's like,
there's like a group of them who hang
out together now from like listening to
your podcast and from listening to my
podcast and they started their own fucking
podcasts, which is a kind of cool
thing. Fuck it. Because it's spreading.
It's spreading it more, you know,
it's like, it's like people,
the bottom line is you can't
get hierarchical with your
geography because a lot
of people are like, you know,
I just live in Pennsylvania.
There's no one here to have
a good conversation with her.
Wherever the fuck they say they live.
It's like,
I guarantee you're surrounded by people
who want to talk about philosophical
shit.
And when I connect with someone on a
level deeper than just what you had for
lunch and what the,
what will,
you know what fucking clothes are cool
or movies or whatever you say that.
But unless you're in a city,
that's probably not the
case. Dude. I was just in,
well, you know, yeah. That I, I depending
on how old your especially, Oh man,
all we all I know is that like,
I don't want to sound like too,
like weirdly
having myself on the back, but it's you
like when go to these fucking shows, dude,
there's thousands of fucking people there.
Yeah.
And when you talk to them after the show,
they're all really fucking cool and they
didn't all just come from metropolitan
areas.
These people are coming from different
towns and cities and then they have,
but they have access to
us. They don't, they might
not have access to people near them.
That's what I'm saying,
that also sharing those interests.
It might not be anybody around them
like that you might think there is,
but unless they're in a, a really, uh,
a large area where there's a
lot of people to choose from,
you might not be correct. It takes a
lot of people, a lot of focus to break,
to get the group of 2000 people that
will come to see one of our shows.
You got to go through hundreds
of thousands of regular
people to find those 2000
disenfranchise people that
really want to say fuck.
Yet Duncan Trussell to
a little Hobo Bitch.
You know the people that listen to
this podcast, that people that, look,
I've had people come up to me,
they'd say, I hate the word cunt.
And then I loved your podcast. The first
time I heard you say con, it bugged me,
but now I say it every day. Now
everything's a con to everyone's a con.
She's a contest is a comp. My
Cat's account, my sister's a cunt.
And it just becomes a
part of your vernacular.
And that's I'm nothing I'm proud of.
But that's the type of
thing that can happen.
And if it can happen with something bad
or stupid or ridiculous like the word
cunt,
it can happen with any sort of idea.
Any idea can get through because of
a podcast like the idea of, you know,
treating each other,
treating each other really as if we
are ourselves living in another life.
The idea of recognizing that this
really is a temporary situation, Shit,
duration, temporary situation and
you need to live it, you lead,
need to live this bitch up.
Okay,
because you're not going to
feel good unless you do. If you,
you hang back and be that guy that you
described earlier who was 30 well we
jumped forward, you'll get
my shit together and then
40 and still have a career.
But Hey man, I got a good job. I'm
going to keep it for a little while.
Maybe I'm going to learn
how to be an apprentice.
And then one day he's dead
and he his ride and Keel over.
Then it could be a guy like you,
a guy who's kind of peaks and
valleys and had dry spots and,
and now is riding this new crazy wave
where you sort of just figured out how to
get on the board. Really fucking travel.
Yeah. Yeah. That's a fucking cool thing,
man. It's because it's right there and
it just requires a kind of like a, um,
you just have to fucking, it's really,
so the thing is, it's so fucking simple.
It's like, and it's not, it's not
because to have access to people,
it's not simple by any stretch of the
imagination to have the right ideas. Sure.
But to, in order to get those
ideas in front of people,
that takes a heroic effort,
man.
I just like the thing that
I'm hesitating to say,
cause I don't want it to
sound fucking coffee is like,
I really do think that
people can like organize.
I do believe that in wherever you're at,
man, there's gotta be something that,
there's ways that you can fucking figure
out other people who like have that we
talk about here. Well,
I think through Twitter,
that's one way we can find out people
that are interested in the same kind of
shows that you're interested in and you
find out that you're in your job. Hey,
where's the cool motherfuckers
up in Tallahassee?
And you put that up on Twitter and you
know, put Tallahassee is a attach Hashtag.
Actually now people are doing it
back and forth. That's it dude.
And it's like that,
that it's really fucking important because
it's not just good enough to exist in
fucking digital space
with people you need.
It's like something about
getting into fucking meat space
with people and like exchanging
ideas and like being around people.
It like it.
Uh,
it kind of shines a light and the shadowy
darkness that can come in to you if
you've isolated yourself because you
feel like you're a psychotic freak with
insane ideas, you know, instead
of realizing like, no man,
a lot of people are thinking this
shit right now. A lot of people are,
a lot of people are willing to entertain
all sorts of alternative ideas.
You'd be amazed and they're around
you. You know, like Margo, boy,
Matt stags and down and where's the
Mississippi or some shit, it's Tennessee.
Something like that. Yeah.
Which Nashville is in Tennessee,
Tennessee as boss response as
those Mississippi. But you know,
he doesn't want to fucking be there
anymore once I get out of there.
The Internet,
the Internet.
Well I think stags is definitely like
a on the precipice of some crazy shit
happening cause he's like definitely
becoming like a conduit for a lot of crazy
ideas and he always hooks me up with
like some with great guests and he's
running the disinfect podcast too.
Yeah. So that's happening soon.
I have to get with them,
but yeah, it's um, we're,
we're living in a strange
time of transition. Um, I'm,
I'm really curious to see,
I think there's the whole Terence
Mckenna 2012 thing is like I,
I always,
I always laughed.
I always thought it would be
really cool if it was true,
but I'm way too stupid to really
understand any of the science behind it,
even if it's real or not.
Or the arguments behind it.
Like I saw the Watson disagreement
or I think it was called,
but Watson objection to Watson objection
was a a mathematician who deciphered
the TimeWave zero novelty theory
and had his own objection to it.
Fucking they both lost weight within the
first paragraph. I was like, Oh fuck.
You're saying there's also less complex
mathematical reputations. The theory,
and I've heard that just like you know,
leap year wasn't accounted for since
2012 happened sometime ago. So it's like,
you know the,
the the again,
but this is like people getting caught
up in the surface level shit and trying
to like no, no, it's not going to happen
on December 21st, 2012 and trying to like,
but it's like no, look what's happening
around you. I wonder if what they,
they calculated when the calculated
the Mayan calendars besides you know,
the moons, the, the, the
rather the eclipse of the moon
and the eclipse of the sun.
I wonder if they could calculate how
long it would take for a culture to grow
before it imploded.
I wonder if there's like just a us,
just a set number of like a
culture can only last for,
it's like you could run and
then you fall down. Yeah.
And they figured that out a long time ago.
They're good for like these 10,000
year pulses or whatever the fuck it is.
There's a guy, he's a easy, if you,
I bet if you googled extinction theorist
right now, that's what he's called.
He's a, he's a, he's also the guy who's
like into simulation theory too. Um,
and he's,
you know,
he's tries to answer that question while
we haven't encountered aliens species.
And it is this notion that
they implode in on themselves.
I can't remember if it's on Youtube.
I wish I can't remember his fucking name.
He's brilliant.
I put a clip of him on,
of my podcasts when the same podcast
that I was talking about. Uh,
the guy from the University of
Maryland because he was, he was,
he was the one who was talking
about the idea of vivisected.
The human brain are slicing it into,
um,
fucking a thin,
thin layers to scan the neurology.
I've done got no extinction theorist.
Shit man.
I can't remember his fucking name.
He's Barilla.
There's evolutionary theory of course.
But um,
last dinosaur extinction theory.
No.
If you look up simulation theory
and theory like studies, this shit,
it's a really weird like ways that we can,
ways that are a species could blink out.
Oh so,
so many ways.
Anywhere.
It's what the fuck is his name
and his got him. Brilliant.
Have you seen those um,
the impact of uh,
meteors a meteor shower
all over the world.
They discovered 12,000 years ago you told
me about this shit and the sedimentary
layers. Yeah, they've done core samples
and it's the same spot all over the globe.
And it's the same sort of shit that exists
when you have nuclear bombs going off
and it makes like a glass
so little,
the world got pelted by fucking giant
chunks of rock gets flowed sound of that
ship bursting through breaking.
The fucking sound barrier is,
it goes rocketing down into
the fucking earth. Boom, boom.
That must've been fucked up man. I wonder
if they had writing back then. Cause,
I don't know if we know that they had
writing 12,000 years ago. I know it,
it all dependent upon
whether or not that event,
that 12,000 year old event was really
the sort of mass extinction event that
like Graham Hancock and a lot of
people think might've happened to, uh,
to human culture or cute humankind
rather the human species because they,
they,
you know,
there's a lot of speculation about
like when is the oldest civilization?
And they pretty much settle on Mesopotamia
and they set them on like Sumeria.
But the,
the,
the Sumerian text details along
lost civilization and older advanced
civilization,
like the kind of all,
do they all talk about some dudes
existed before really had it down. Yeah.
And Samira was supposed to
be like 6,000 this years ago.
So imagine if that's what it was.
So 6,000 year track from the
time that they got pelted with,
we can wrap our heads around how
long that is. That's so long ago,
but yet nothing, you know, in its greater
spectrum of the universe, nothing.
But in the, the, the idea of
our lifetime, 6,000 years old,
long fucking time ago,
and they talked about an old civilization
and old ancient civilization that
existed that was wiped
out the epic of Gilgamesh,
which is essentially very similar to
the Noah's Ark story about, about it.
Cataclysmic flood. Yeah.
Floods. Yeah. They uh,
they probably experienced
some fucking nutty shit, man.
It probably killed almost everybody.
That's probably,
that probably explains a of Shit. A lot
of shit all over the world. Like gold,
Beckley,
Tat Bay,
all these weird structures that
they're finding from pre 12,000 years.
There's a beck go Beckley
templates 14,000 years ago.
That means in Sumeria,
the really old shit in Sumeria
is like 6,000 plus years ago,
7,000 plus years ago.
This is double that.
So this is as old to Sumeria as we
are to Sumeria as soon Maoris to us,
that's the distance,
the distance of people writing on clay
tablets and scratches and these little
scratches up and down and sideways.
That was their whole language. And the,
the idea that they wrote of something
from 7,000 years previous maybe,
and that's what go Beckley topic shows.
It shows that there was a sophisticated
civilization from 7,000 years prior to
the, the people in Sumeria and the people
in Mesopotamia 7,000 years earlier,
they were making these 19 foot tall,
gigantic stone columns.
They were carved with animals that were
carved in a relief so that like they
stuck out, which is a really
sophisticated method of carving.
You're not carving into the stone.
You're actually making a relief.
It sticks out so you chipped all the rest
of the stone away to reveal this frog
and to reveal this bird.
And this is really sophisticated stuff.
It's hard for people to
wrap their heads around it.
So when they start talking to him about
like hunter and gatherers from, you know,
wearing skins around their dick, that
these are the ones that built this boy,
I don't know. I don't know. This is a you,
you might have more evidence of the fact
that there might've been some really
super advanced cultures.
They got fucking pelted.
Just wiped out everybody. No talking
anymore changed languages. No,
no fucking written shit. No one
knows how to write the fucking road.
Like it was like the road
nuclear ash falling down.
Just fucking,
just decimation.
Well by studying genetics,
I believe that they've found several
extinction events in the human genome.
Like they've isolated several events. I
don't understand the science behind this.
I really am talking like
extremely deep out of my ass,
but I believe they've shown
that um, when studying the, the,
the DNA from different human
beings of all over the world,
they've concluded that there've been
several times where the human species has
gotten very low as low as like a few
thousand people and that, you know,
we probably had a big number and then a
much smaller number and it got as low as
a few thousand people and then we
had to recover. It's fucking amazing.
It's amazing what they found out
just by studying genes. You know,
you will live in this kind of like that.
One of the ideas of like the,
the Freemasons are the rosy cruise
shins are the secret societies.
Is that that information
from a very long time ago,
it's been kept secret like yeah,
they sit but they kind of
work signs do each other.
They work symbols into the
architecture of society. Right.
Which is that fucking crazy guy.
Damn. If you look at this, the,
the street configurations
of Washington DC,
have you seen that shit where it's like
a anatomically correct eyeball looking
out over a pyramid? Just like the
I and the dollar bill. I mean,
come on dude.
How do you, how do you, how
would you describe that? If
I was going to Google that,
a masonic symbols and d c I don't know.
Washington DC, my sonic
Washington DC road roads are guys,
I don't know fucking,
well it's you stoned to Google.
I want to go with masonic symbols
in DC. Yup. Here it is. Yeah.
The um, they have it laid out. Yeah.
Wow.
I mean that's, that's like you got to
really believe you have a Pentagram. Yeah.
There's a Pentagram in there.
There's a a fucking awesome.
So, so strange. Yeah, there's an
eye, there's an optic nerve and I,
there's a Pentagram.
It's real weird when you look at like
the money and you see the fucking all
seeing eye in a pyramid on the cap
of the pyramid is the all seeing eye.
Like what are you saying?
I mean look man, printing
it on money. Okay,
but how about putting into the Goddamn
geography of the fucking capitol of the
country that you made?
Trying to embody the ideals that you know,
you knew and you encoded into the
fucking very patterns. I mean,
look man, there's a goddamn
monolith. The Washington monument,
an obelisk and Egyptian fucking obelisk
rising up out of our nation's capitol.
Yeah. Remember how the Egyptians
helped with the revolutionary war?
Cause I know they were there for us. Yeah.
They came over and provided us with a,
uh,
what's,
what's even crazier is that Egypt at
one point in time was thriving and then
it's, this was nothing
there. Like they, they,
they showed up and the spanx was like
covered up to its neck like during the age
of Napoleon when they, when they first
found that it was like a fucking,
everything is abandoned. They'd already
alluded all these different tombs.
Who knows how much really incredible
shit was melted down for gold baubles and
shit when they didn't
understand historical worth.
Well, I mean, dude,
that I like one thing that like over
time the time has proven again and again
and again is that shit doesn't always
work out great for the smart people with
good ideas. You end up getting thrown into
basements by dumb people who are like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Galileo, they ended up in prison in you.
Sometimes they crucify you,
sometimes they embarrass you,
sometimes they take away your property.
So over time,
really smart people were like,
you know what,
why don't we just fucking
keep this shit to ourselves?
Well, you know, that's it. The
theory behind the mushrooms and
the church, that's the theory. Uh,
I mean a lot of this was a
young Urban's work and, um,
another dude who died who turned
out to be a child molester,
but he did a lot of really good work,
uh, with, um, with the, with mushrooms,
with the historical,
and he was writing a book with Jack Herer
when he got arrested for being a child
molester.
This guy fucked up Jack Herer because of
fucked up the research and were really
like sort of invalidated and a lot of
people's ideas like this work this guy had
done.
Um,
but they have so many images and photos
of ancient religious art that involves
mushrooms. Symbolism. When you looked
at it over and over and over again,
you're like, oh my God. Like this is so
obvious. Like first of all, the Halos,
the Halos did not look like the,
the Frisbee thing, the Hula Hoop.
They looked like a mushroom cap and they
were circular behind the person's head.
And the idea was to insinuate that that
person that holds the person was under
the influence of God under the
influence of the mushroom. Yes.
And that's totally believable.
And that makes a lot of subtly believable.
And the images of the doors,
they're shaped like mushrooms,
doorways are shaped like one is mushroom
symbolism and so many different places.
And there was so many
images of people in bliss,
naked in bliss covered in a mushroom.
They would be in a transparent mushroom.
These are like fucking ancient paintings.
I mean, yeah, it's definitely like we,
we do know that there are encoded into
the fucking a framework of our society
and the Goddamn architecture of our
society. Or it's a very odd symbols.
Like if you look at the
um, uh, the cathedrals,
you will find gnostic sim
symbols, chicken, God's Abraxis.
You can see Abraxis in some
cathedrals. What does a chicken, God,
it's some gnostic fucking God
you can Wikipedia praxis. It's,
this happens to be the same name of the
company doing this goddamn trap wire
shit too. Yeah. Look up Abraxis
gnostic Abraxas at chicken headache.
How do you spell it? A. B. R a.
N praxis access Abraxis gnostic Wikipedia.
For some reason,
the creepiest God damn information
gathering surveillance company that's ever
climbed out of the shadows or been exposed
to happen to name themselves after a
gnostic God with a chicken
head. What the fuck man? Yeah,
go figure a chicken. God. Well
this thing is freaky looking. Yeah,
it's freaky looking and
that's in cathedrals. They
like, it's like a lot of the,
the um, the, that, you know,
a lot of these symbols,
they what they think it feeds roles
were apparently I read this and I can't
remember the name.
It's one of Graham Hancock's books that
fucking stag sent me cause he's trying
to drive me insane. But one of the, but,
but, but um, but yeah, like in the,
in this fucking book it talks about how
the cathedrals were like a nexus where,
um, a person's shoulders, a
chicken man chose it as a, ma'am,
I've seen the one with the chicken. It's
definitely a chicken. Oh, that's weird.
Because this one, uh, this image is
a man. Look, Google Abraxis chicken.
Okay. Fast gnostic chicken and
fucking Nashville. It's a great
name for a fucking chicken for
this man. Abraxis chicken. Chicken,
God. Chicken. God. Yeah. Just a
braxet chicken. It's got chicken.
Okay.
No, I'm looking at my main for chicken.
Abraxis it comes up right away.
Let's see.
Abraxis it comes up.
Do an image search but the chicken
doesn't come up. Do you want to name it?
Emits emits. Oh yeah. I'm
the images is one of them.
Where it looks like a chicken.
It's a fucking chicken. Well it's crazy
though. It's a chicken holding a um, uh,
a mallet. Yeah. One of those
things. A shield on one side. Wow.
What a fucking freak animal.
Yeah, it's freaky. Jesus Christ.
And what we, what year is
this from? I have no idea.
So they were high when they
came up with that, right? Yeah.
There's no other way I chicken
with a shield. Chicken. God,
how are you going to definitely take
different, you're drawing a chicken.
This chicken guy. Wow. There's all this
crazy images of it where it looked like a,
like a heartbeat or something. No read
it. Read the Wikipedia entry a little bit.
Cause gnostic shits very strange.
I just re read like a little passage
from there. Cause it's really odd.
It's like real mysterious.
Oh,
praxis Abraxis far more common in the
sources than the variant from Abraxis on
different boxes. It's all, they're
using Greek Greek letters. The word, uh,
of mystic,
meaning in the system of
the gnostic baselines,
baselines, B, a, s, I, l. I, d, e s being,
they're applied to the great art con and
our Crm, our con one of the greatest,
see 64 games. It really, uh,
NASA cosmology and blah, blah,
blah. The seven lower spelling,
his name represent each of the
seven classic, uh, planets. Wow.
The Ne, the words, if it's the
letters represent planets, the sun,
the moon, mercury, Venus,
Mars, Jupiter, and Saturn.
The word was found in gnostic text.